Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Schon gehört, Armin Laschet hat jetzt seinen Zukunftsteam vorgestellt.
Es bleiben im Raum jung, prima, März und Bär.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer vierhundertfünf vom ähm was haben wir denn heute? Vierter September 212. Und während Armin Laschet das äh letzte Aufgebot
aus dem Keller holt ähm haben wir ein neues Angebot für euch, einen bunten äh Themenstrauß und ähm so sollte es ja auch sein, ne? Und äh
wir haben auch einen Gast, ne?
Ja, wir haben einen Gast, Überraschungsgast. Äh wir haben ja, wir reden ja hier viel über äh die Regierungs,
Partei CDU und die vielen Missstände, für die sie verantwortlich ist in diesem Lande. Und aus diesem Grunde haben wir uns einfach mal Armin Laschet eingeladen. Armin, vielleicht magst du dich kurz vorstellen.
Wunderbar, dann haben wir ein gemeinsames Ziel jetzt endlich, das freut freut uns dann doch, dass wir hier den Schulterschluss wieder äh gefunden haben, ja? Wir wir ein Vogel.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Ja und seine äh ja,
Ich weiß nicht, ob bei ob er ob er die richtige Methode anwendet, um hier ähm zum Erfolg zu kommen, je nachdem, welchen Erfolg er jetzt meint, das weiß man ihm ja nicht so ganz genau, ne?
Ja
Also diese, die
wir lachen ja hier äh seit bald zehn Jahren über über die Misere und das ist auch das häufigste äh Feedback, das wir äh so bekommen, dass die Leute sich freuen, dass wir trotz
obwohl wir eigentlich nur schlechte Nachrichten behandeln, ähm unsere gute Laune dabei nicht verlieren
das ist das ist ja keine gute Laune die wir davon bekommen sondern die wir das ist ja eher so 'ne so 'ne historische Grundstimmung,
das ist halt nicht mehr reicht zum Heulen, ja? Und äh wir deshalb lachen müssen.
Du weißt, wir lachen gar nicht, sondern war nur hysterisches Gekicher am Start.
Was anderes kannst du gar nicht mehr machen, ja. Äh aber wir werden in dieser Sendung ein bisschen darüber sprechen, ähm,
wie wir uns denn wen wir so für die Gesamtsituation verantwortlich machen in diesem Lande und was wir hoffen daran zu ändern. Aber als allererstes müssen wir natürlich.
Nochmal die HTTP-Status kurz behandeln.
Genau, das ist nämlich die passende Fehlermeldung eigentlich für die CDU, ne.
Vier null fünf. Ja, also hat die P ist ja wirklich ein,
Eine Wundertüte, ne? Da also man benutzt eigentlich das Allerwenigste davon
Wie das immer so ist, so bestimmte äh äh Dinge werden immer nur zu einem gewissen Maß sehr viel verwendet, aber können eigentlich auch eine ganze Menge mehr, wenn man mal tiefer reinschaut. Und da gibt's dann zum Beispiel auch dieses weithin unbekannte Konzept einer
Methode. Das ist nämlich das, wenn ihr auf irgendeiner Webseite rumklickt. Dann sagt ihr, äh in erst mal quasi äh schickt ihr ein,
ja eine Methode, ein Kommando, quasi so eine eine Anfrage,
und und und was ihr eigentlich genau wollt, das das ist eben diese sogenannte HTP-Methode und wenn man immer so klickt, dann macht man immer nur ich will, ich will, ich will, ich will.
Also so was wie Index HTML.
Ja genau, get, irgendwie, ich will jetzt einfach hier diese Ressource lesen, weil Web ist ja äh zum Lesen da und Internet ist zum downloaden
genau das Ding so, ne?
Gibt aber auch noch ein paar andere Methoden, die man jetzt äh selten sieht und die Nerds natürlich in der Regel kennen, wenn man Formular abschickt, dann ist das ein Post oder wenn man nur irgendwie mal gucken will, ob so eine Seite überhaupt da wäre, einen der Inhalte aber nicht interessiert, dann kann man auch einfach nur nach dem
Fragen, dann ist es ein oder wenn man was hochlädt, dann ist es ein Putt und dann gibt's auch noch ganz viele andere Sachen, die eigentlich überhaupt
äh für gar nichts weiter äh wichtig sind. Nur äh wenn halt der Server eine nicht kennt, dann ist es ein 405. Lieber am.
Wenn er sie nicht wenn er sie nicht erlaubt.
Ja. So und irgendwie kein Internet installieren in Deutschland und äh die Klimakrise befördern, ist definitiv auch eine nicht erlaubte Methode. Armin.
Ich habe, ich habe äh tatsächlich äh also der der Statuscode vor mir nicht so bekannt. Und ich erinnere mich an einen äh Fall vor einiger Zeit, wo ich ähm,
weil äh.
Wenn man Notsituationspatchen machen musste, weil es eine Schwachstelle auf einem Server gab und um diese Schwachstelle auszunutzen, brauchte man einen Post-Request-Post, ist ja die übliche Methode, um eben,
Daten zu übermitteln, ja? Also man man schickt etwas dahin, also an einen bestimmten Endpunkt und postet dort Daten hin. Man kann auch mit einem gettrig Fest,
quasi Daten übermitteln, die sind dann aber quasi Teil der URL, beim Postfrequest ist es das nicht. Jedenfalls musste ich dort schnell,
verhindern, dass überhaupt noch irgendwelche Post-Request von dem äh Server akzeptiert werden. Und dann habe ich halt äh einfach gesagt, okay, wenn Post, dann vier null vier.
Und das war falsch, ja. Hätte 405, die wäre die korrekte, die korrekte äh äh Regel gewesen, dass ich ihnen sage, Posts erlauben wir hier nicht mehr.
Ich lerne hier auch.
Ja, genau, also noch 20 Sendungen, also bist ein veritabler Webprobe im Jahr geworden.
Ja zumindest äh zumindest mal mit Statuskurs. Äh das ist wirklich äh Spaß mit Statuscodes. Es es ist äh
durchaus äh wichtig da mal richtige die Codes richtig zu zu berücksichtigen. Das ist auch wenn man also insbesondere wenn man so.
Bastelt.
Gilt ja generell ehrlich, wenn's um Computer geht und auch sonst im Leben immer alles richtig machen.
Immer alles richtig machen. Das ist das erspart einfach so viel Ärger, ja. Das äh kann man, kann man gar nicht, kann man gar nicht anders sagen. Wir haben bisschen äh Feedback
gehabt zur zur insbesondere zu der Apple Sendung, aber wir fangen mal kurz an mit Feedback zu der Quad-Nine-Sendung, das fand ich also der letzten Sendung mit Julia Reeder.
Da sagte, das fand ich eigentlich einen ganz netten Austausch. Und mich Andreas sagte, und dass das diesen Austausch zwischen Andreas und Martino äh finde ich so äh
zeigt halt sehr äh äh klar, was Sony da macht. Also Andreas fragt, was würde Sony denn wohl machen, wenn Quart neun oder Kort Nein alle Sony Seiten
und Abmahnweltanwälte aus deren Resolver löscht
Stimmt, genau, dann würden sie nämlich quengeln. Jetzt kommt aber die Antwort von Martino, nichts, wie in der Sendung erwähnt, dürfte der Anteil der Nutzer, die überhaupt in der Lage sind, ihren DNS-Server zu ändern, bereits irrelevant klein sein? Vermutlich merken sie es nicht einmal. Und,
das finde ich in diesem Austausch offenbart sich sehr äh was was Sony da nämlich genau gerade eigentlich spielt und das haben wir auch in der Sendung äh sehr schön,
von Julia seziert bekommen.
Genau.
Und dann gab es äh die Sendung davor haben wir uns über diese Apple-Geschichte unterhalten und Herr Yemin, ne da gab es aber ganz viele Kommentare.
Ja, da hatte jeder, jeder was äh von sich zu geben. Ich glaube, wir sind gerade bei 128 Kommentaren und dazu da bezog sich der Großteil natürlich auf diese Sesamdiskussion, muss mich jetzt nicht gar nicht groß überrascht, weil es ist ja
schon im Thema angelegt, so dass das einfach ein ein Punkt ist, wo ja, die verschiedensten Meinungen existieren.
Und das hat sich da halt auch gezeigt,
teilweise war's ein bisschen wild äh fand ich so, also manche vor allem hatten so den Eindruck, dass wir uns jetzt hier irgendwie ähm gestritten hätten. Ich hatte diesen Eindruck, ehrlich gesagt.
Gar nicht.
Nee, ich auch nicht. Also, das ähm also, wir haben äh angeregt über dieses Thema diskutiert.
Und äh ich hoffe, äh dass auf allen klar war, dass wir es auf einer inhaltlichen Ebene tun
und nicht auf einer äh auf einer persönlichen, die jetzt irgendwie dazu führt, dass wir uns streiten oder jetzt es zum Bruch käme oder oder sonstiges, ja? Das äh hoffe ich, dass da niemand den falschen Eindruck beigewonnen hätte.
Nee und ich meine auf der anderen Seite, äh also wenn's euch lieber ist, dass wir hier immer irgendwie äh unisono immer nur mit so einer äh Mehrheitsmeinung äh unterwegs sind so, weiß ich nicht, ob ihr dann im richtigen Programm angekommen seid.
Man muss äh die Sachen einfach auch mal von verschiedenen Seiten beleuchten. Sonst ähm
Versteht man sie halt teilweise auch einfach mal gar nicht. Insbesondere, was so diesen politischen Prozess betrifft,
Gibt's ja auch immer noch Leute, die das einfach mal ganz anders sehen. So und nicht immer tun sie das
äh aus bösen Erwägungen, sondern einfach nur, weil sie es anders sehen, weil sie es nicht besser wissen oder nie anders erklärt bekommen haben. Und äh auch da muss man sich mal langsam mal reinversetzen. So
die ganze Diskussion rund um dieses äh
Feature, was Apple angekündigt hat, was ja viele Leute, vor allem deshalb verstört, weil das halt eine Komponente aufs Telefon auslagert wurde, sowas normalerweise oder zumindest bei anderen bisher so noch nicht stattgefunden hat. Auch wenn Apple das immer äh verteidigt hat als einen.
Privatsphäre schonen den Ansatz. Diese ganze äh Debatte ist ziehen, hat ziemlich an Fahrt äh gewonnen. Hatte sie schon, als wir darüber berichtet haben, aber es hat danach auch nicht unbedingt nachgelassen
und äh Apple hat jetzt angekündigt, dass sie wohl nicht, wie das ursprünglich angedacht war mit dem Release von iOS 15 und allen anderen Betriebssystemen, die in dem Moment äh rauskommen, auch mit US et cetera, die
die neue Version, dass sie das dann noch nicht einschalten, sondern dass sie erstmal über das Feedback nachdenken wollen.
Ums dann zum späteren Zeitpunkt äh zu liefern.
Selber aber auch sehr spezifisch gesagt, äh dieses wichtige Feature wollen sie nach wie vor verfolgen, ne. Also sie haben.
Klar gesagt, dass sie nicht von dem Plan abrücken, äh etwas zu tun, aber sich nochmal damit auseinandersetzen, was und wie sie das machen.
Das ist auch typisch eigentlich typisch Apple. So, ich meine.
Einfach typisch PR.
Es ist aber, ne, es ist insofern typisch äh Apple auch, weil sie die,
schon bei allen Sachen, wo sie äh vermuten, dass das unter Umständen, wenn's einfach nur so ausgerollt wird, zu viel Wind führt, dass sie das halt
vorher ankündigen und dann die Debatte ähm sozusagen auch akzeptieren und äh äh mitnehmen,
gesundabhängig darf, zu welchen Ergebnissen sie dann kommen, ne, aber das haben sie nicht das erste Mal getan.
Ja, ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, dass Apple sich.
Also die die trinken da ja alle in ihrem komischen Kreis da die gleiche coole Aid und ich äh glaube, dass die wahrscheinlich echt überrascht waren,
Ja, ähm dass ihnen das so ins Gesicht geflogen ist, weil äh das ist ja der Teil, den man vielleicht schon mal,
würdigen muss, verglichen mit hier ist die Cloud, wir scannen alles, was da drin ist, ist das ja wirklich ein sehr ähm.
Technisch,
Ansatz mit einer ganzen Reihe an äh Safeguards, die sie da drin haben. Und ich denke, dass sie wahrscheinlich schon gedacht haben, sie würden dafür,
Applaus bekommen für das, was sie da vorgeschlagen haben. Zum Beispiel, also nur mal, äh wenn ich jetzt, also ich denke mich jetzt mal in so ein Apple PR.
Typen rein, vor.
Ja, wenn wir das dann etwas über einem Jahr hat sie das äh äh mit Google zusammen dieses Expose, Exposur Notification Framework, also die Corona-Warn-App.
Grundlage entwickelt haben, ja? Und bekannt gegeben haben
äh das hätte ja also das hätte ja auch sein können, dass dann ihr irgendwie, dass die Stimmung kippt und alle sagen, Alter, jetzt verschwören sich Google und Apple gegen uns und wollen unsere,
Smartphones zu Trekkingwanzen bauen, aber weil sie gesagt haben, hier wir machen das so und so und haben das ordentlich erklärt. Kryptographische Primitiven dargelegt und äh äh und halt wirklich etwas durchdachtes präsentiert, äh ist das ja gemeinhin sehr positiv aufgenommen worden.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie dachten, dass sie sich ähm mit dieser Sache jetzt in einer ähnlichen Situation befinden, zu sagen, schaut her.
Wir haben für dieses große Problem eine total elegante Lösung, Kraft unserer Genialität geschaffen. Ich glaube nicht, dass das die äh irgendwie schon da saßen und den Helm auf hatten, als sie die Sache veröffentlicht haben. Gleichzeitig, was ich gerade meinte, typisch PR.
Ähm einfaches Beispiel, Uploadfilterdebatte ist, als das auf der EU-Ebene diskutiert wurde,
riesig ins äh äh riesige Öffentlichkeit, ne, irgendwelche Youtuber haben da äh rumgeschrien in in Berlin und was nicht alles, ja? Aber das durch einfaches Aussitzen in die Länge ziehen.
Und den Artikel 13 umbenennen und was nicht alles, ja? Ähm hast du das am Ende sang und klanglos durch den Bundestag bekommen?
Ja? Und äh das ist, glaube ich, die der Gewinn, den Apple auf jeden Fall jetzt verbuchen kann,
ist, dass sie sagen, ah super, wir haben den jetzt im Prinzip ein nicht zugeständnis gemacht, nämlich wir machen's paar Monate später oder wir gucken nochmal drüber und diese Energie, die die Leute jetzt gerade haben,
Die ist dann eben wieder woanders. Und dann bauen wir das einfach sangend klanglos ein und und schreiben's in die Release-Nots. Wir haben es ja damals angekündigt.
Effekt
werden sie auf jeden Fall dadurch haben. Die Frage ist, wie groß der ist, ob der ausreichend groß ist für Apple, um das jetzt protestlos äh oder ohne Gegenwehr in die Geräte zu bekommen
oder ob sie vielleicht noch irgendeinen Knopf machen, dass man halt abschalten kann oder was auch immer. Aber auf jeden Fall werden sie, ähm haben sie jetzt erstmal so diese Revelle der Entrüstung den Boden unter den Füßen weggezogen, die Leute haben jetzt irgendeine Form von Eingeständnis,
sind jetzt potenziell erstmal beruhigt und bei der zweiten Welle werden die nicht die gleiche das gleiche Ausmaß an Entrüstung hochkriegen.
Das ist mit Sicherheit so, allerdings erwarte ich also so wie ich den Laden kennengelernt habe, erwarte ich, dass sie.
Schon auf eine bestimmte Kritik eingehen werden. Ich denke, sie werden im Kern das Feature so erhalten.
Aber sie werden unter Umständen nochmal bei den Safeguards nochmal aufrüsten in irgendeiner Form. Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt keine konkrete Vermutung habe, wo genau und wie genau sie das tun werden.
Wir gucken mal, wie sich das weiter entwickelt, aber es ist äh immerhin ähm auch ähm AdWords Snowden war ja einer der äh auch der äh.
Dieses Planes, der jetzt auch äh irgendwie so schrieb zu sagen, haben sie sich wohl vertan, wie viel äh wie laut wir kreischen können oder uns dagegenwenden können
wie viel Lärm wir machen können und es ist natürlich, ist das äh auch ein ein wichtiger Punkt. Also ich will das jetzt so unabhängig von ähm.
Der Technik oder was auch immer, ist es das ist ein Unternehmen mit sehr vielen Kunden und das ist schon auch mal spannend zu sehen, dass dass diese Kunden sich eben gegen etwas wehren und ähm das in einem Ausmaß tun.
Dass das Unternehmen zumindest von seinen Plänen abrücken muss, ne. Ähm das sollten wir beibehalten.
Sie hätten ja, ich meine Apple hätte ja immer bei der CDU fragen können, weil die verstehen was von Digitalisierung, ne?
Also, ich hatte Spaß auf Twitter, ich hatte Spaß auf Twitter, Tim. Ich habe ja immer Spaß auf Twitter, weil weil du.
Das ist da die Gelegenheit, später mal ein Museum ausgestellt zu werden, ne? Hier, der Mensch, der Spaß auf Twitter hatte.
Ja, das stimmt. Es ist tatsächlich so. Ich meine, man kann sich ja ähm hm.
Also, wie Leute, die so giftig werden in, in Online-Diskussionen, ist ja schon, sage ich mal, sehr unterhaltsam, ja? Und äh ich habe ja mehrere Vorträge auch schon darüber gehalten, äh wie,
wie ich auf diese Sachen blicke, ne? Äh die Kunst des Trollens oder sowas hieß einer und äh.
Oder getreut werden ein paar Vorträge darüber gehalten mit welcher
Freu mit welcher Freude ich sehe, wenn Leute halt so richtig wütend werden im Internet. Und ähm hier ist folgendes passiert. Ähm
Dorothee Bär, eine äh Person, die in diesem Podcast selten äh Würdigung,
erfährt, weil sie in unserem Themenfeld der Netzpolitik äh nicht in nennenswert in Erscheinung tritt,
Ja. Ähm das ist etwas erstaunlich, weil sie ist, ist das habe ich ähm gemerkt, äh oder habe ich nochmal geprüft, sie ist nach wie vor Staatsministerin im Bundeskanzleramt für Digitalisierung.
Ja? Das war äh einer der Posten, die zu Beginn dieses äh Kabinetts Merkel vier ähm,
Digitalministerium gehandelt wurden. Ja, es gab ja dann irgendwie, ich glaube.
Wirtschaftsminister hat gesagt, ich bin der digitale Minister, Verkehrsminister hat gesagt, ich bin der Digitalminister äh Dorothee Bär, die äh Beauftragte der Bundesregierung hat gesagt, ich bin Digitalminister und gab's ja nicht noch einen vierten.
War eine Regierung davor. Ja, ja, es gab ganz viele.
Nee. Ach, nee, nee, nee, ne.
Hier so mit Sigmar Gabriel und so weiter ging das ja schon los, diese Aufteil.
Ja, weil sie ist, sie ist das erst seit 20018 und ich weiß, dass sie da eine von denen war, wo sie sagten, wir haben jetzt Digitalminister. Es wird jedes Jahr gesagt, wir haben jetzt äh es wird nach jeder Wahl gesagt, wir haben jetzt einen Digitalminister, es wird auch vor jeder Wahl diskutiert, ob wir einen Digitalministerium brauchen.
Aber ist ihre ihr Posten, den sie da hat, äh wird gemeinhin auch als Digitalministerin,
bezeichnet, ja? Ist natürlich keine Ministerin, weil sie ist ja, äh sie ist Staatsministerin
der Bundeskanzlerin. Ähm und das ist, glaube ich, so, ja, vergleichbar wie mit jetzt Helge Braun, der äh Kanzleramtsminister ist ja auch kein Minister, aber der Leiter des Kanzleramtes und so weiter,
Das ist sie also, man könnte sagen, eine der ähm,
eine Digitalpolitikerin mit sehr großen Einflussmöglichkeiten.
In der Bundesrepublik Deutschland äh mit denen sie sehr ähm verantwortungsbewusst und sparsam umgeht.
Du weißt auch, wie sie in diese Rolle gekommen ist, was was ihre Kernqualifikation in der CDU war, um überhaupt so eine zentrale Rolle äh in der Digitalisierung einzunehmen.
Sie war die mit dem Twitter-Account.
Sie war die Erste, die er irgendwie da rumge äh twittert hat und da irgendwie das aktiv äh benutzt hat. Ist schon eine Weile her, so, aber so fing das mal an.
Ne? Ich meine das ist nicht so, dass sie jetzt mit irgendwie richtiger Kompetenz
daherkommen würden und mal irgendwas damit zu tun gehabt hätten oder so. Nee, es war halt einfach nur die, die sich irgendwie mit den Social Media Networks irgendwie äh gelegt hat und irgendwie noch jung genug war, um sich nicht sofort zu schämen.
Für das, was sie schreibt. Ja, und von daher war's halt erste Wahl.
Im Land der der Blinden ja war sie dann die einäugige.
Was was also da ist sie auf jeden Fall jung geblieben, dass sie sich nicht sofort schämen für das, was sie schreibt.
Äh kann man auf jeden Fall sagen, da ist sie sich treu geblieben.
Was ist passiert? Was ist passiert? Äh Dorothee Bär twittert folgenden Inhalt.
Wissenschaftlich belegt, Doppelpunkt. Die Union, CDU, CSU hat das digitalste Bundestagswahlprogramm.
Das ist das Ergebnis einer wissenschaftlichen Analyse der TU München und der Uni Kaiserslautern.
Wir sind die Parteien der Zukunft. So, das twittert Dorothee Bär. Ähm.
In Zukunft auch, wie es sich gehört, mit C geschrieben? Aha.
Nein, mit Z. Ja.
Dorothee Bär verkündet, etwas ist wissenschaftlich belegt. Ja, ohne, ohne, ohne den Beleg anzubringen, ja? Also es fehlt jetzt der Link zu der Studie oder so, ne?
Oder einem Artikel, der äh der diese belegte Aussage.
Ihrer Meinung nach wissenschaftlich belegte Aussage äh vertritt oder formuliert. So, es geht aber weiter.
Der Twitter-Account von Peng, dem Aktionskunstkollektiv, äh das wir ja auch hier in der letzten Sendung besprochen hatten, mit der äh mit der Webseite, für die sie jetzt unter Terrorverdacht gestellt wurden.
Gestellt werden sollen.
Antwortet auf diesen Feed. Sie sind auf eine E-Mail von uns reingefallen. Diese Studie gibt es nicht, wir haben sie verarscht.
So, soweit so schön, ja. Jetzt äh dann habe ich einen Screenshot davon gemacht von diesem Austausch.
Habe getwittert, liebe Doro Bär, ich darf Ihnen zum Millionenerbe eines Nigerianischen Prinzen gratulieren,
Überweisen Sie schnell 10.000 Euro an folgendes Konto, damit wir Ihnen 34 Milliarden US-Dollar überweisen können. Die IBAN, Ihr Elon Musk.
So ähm.
Ich habe gedacht, kann man ja mal versuchen, ja. Ich habe auch weil ich dachte, vielleicht klappt's ja. Habe ich meine eigene IBAN angegeben, ja, um halt auch den Erfolg kontrollieren zu können.
Kam aber dann als Antwort äh von Doro Bär at äh Ziffer. Früher hätte man dich mal witzig finden können, also vielleicht, also ich zwar nicht, aber vielleicht andere gähnen.
Muss ich zugeben, habe ich die Frau unterschätzt. Ja, sie hat's gemerkt, sie ist drauf, sie ist nicht drauf reingefallen. Ich habe auch heute nochmal den Kontostand kontrolliert. Äh sie hat mir nicht zehntausend Euro überwiesen. So.
Muss man auch einfach mal freimütig zugeben, ich habe die gute Frau unterschätzt. So, sie hat mir viel Anlass gegeben, sie zu unterschätzen, aber in diesem Punkt habe ich sie unterschätzt.
Das wäre jetzt äh lustig, wäre jetzt schon lustig genug gewesen. Du hattest ja auch gerade gesagt, so.
Kannte ich diese Studie? Oder wusste ich, ob es die gibt? Ja?
Und ähm ja, natürlich wusste ich, dass es diese Studie gibt, sie war aber noch nicht öffentlich und sagen wir mal so,
Ich hatte ein leichtes, einen leichten Verdacht, dass die Studie nicht wissenschaftlich belegt, dass die Union das digitalste Bundestagswahlprogramm hat.
Ja? Äh einen leichten, so einen leichten Handschuh, ja so dachte ich so, ich glaube nicht.
Hm.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht und wenn das so ist, dann ähm.
Also wenn die Studie das belegt, dann würde ich mir gerne mal den Methodenteil anschauen. Also habe ich den Wissenschaftlern geschrieben, habe gesagt, ja es ist spannende Studie, die sie hier haben.
Woher wusstest du jetzt, von wo die Studie herkommt? Ach so, sie hat ja die Uni benannt.
Ja gesagt, welche Uni und ähm es sprang dann auch das ist eigentlich, das ist der Teil. Es sprang dann so Tagesspiegel Background Leute mit auf.
Die dann so sagt, doch, doch, doch. Die Studie gibt's, die Studie gibt's irgendwie so einer, äh, warte mal, wer, wer war das denn? Ähm,
Den Feed habe ich gar nicht mehr gefunden. Ähm.
Auf jeden Fall hat sie dann einen Hinweis, wo die Studie konkret herkam.
Pass auf. Äh mir antwortete dann, auf also auf meinen Tweet, antwortete mir dann Oliver Voss. Äh Oliver Voss ist äh Journalist beim Tagesspiegel im Team Tagesspiegel Background für Tech KI Startups Digitalwirtschaft.
Davor war ja wohl bei der Wirtschaftswoche. Der antwortet mir.
Sie sind auf einen Tweet von Peng reingefallen. Diesen Fake gibt es nicht. Man hat sie verarscht.
Ey Linus, dass du sowas nicht merkst, ey.
Dass ich sowas nicht merke, ne? Und jetzt muss ich jetzt, jetzt habe ich also einen Tag, an dem ich mit mit der Digitalministerin und einem Journalisten für für,
KI Startups und Digitalwirtschaft im Internet darüber diskutieren, wer wen verarscht, ja? Das heißt, oh ich liebe das Internet. Ich liebe das Internet. Dafür ist es so geil,
Träumchen. Nein, nein, nein, wir haben dich verarscht. Nee, denkste, das ist großartig. Träumchen. Träumchen.
Ähm und äh dann äh wurde, ne? Und ich find's ja auch schön, man äh wie gesagt, der schönste Punkt ist immer dann, wenn Leute dann die äh wenn man merkt, die verlieren jetzt gerade äh den Humor,
Und dann twittert Dorothee Bär jetzt nicht in einem sondern an ihre 1hunderttausend 100 und 3.000 Follower.
Echt? So viel hat die?
Sehr bedenklich, wenn habe euch bislang für eure Verantwortung geschätzt und auch verteidigt. Also denkst du, okay äh.
Aha plurales Majestatis jetzt oder was?
Genau, also das ist finde ich auch in Ordnung, ja, das steht mir irgendwie auch zu, dass ich hier äh plurales Tat ist, aber selbstverständlich meint sie damit äh den Chaos-Computer-Club. Und was ich an diesem, was ich an diesen, also diesen Fit finde ich auch,
Küsschen, ne? Also erstens geschätzt, also von dieser Wertschätzung ist bei uns irgendwie.
Lange nichts angekommen, ja? Ähm und jetzt verteidigt, so. Was, was heißt verteidigt? So, äh,
innerhalb der CDU CSU gesagt, äh nee, die sind gar nicht doof. Ich meine, vor wem verteidigt, habe ich Angst?
Hab ich Angst vor der CDU? Ja, hab ich tatsächlich, also dass die CDU regiert
halte ich für gefährlich und dagegen muss man sich verteidigen, aber ich kann auch echt darauf verzichten, von Dorothee Bärtenkreise der CDU verteidigt zu werden. Wunderschöne Antwort von UD3 X heißt, dass die jahrelange Beziehung zwischen dem CCC und der CSU ist jetzt beendet.
Das.
Erdgeist antwortete darauf, äh wir überdecken jetzt mal unsere Parteispenden.
Es ist einfach also ein richtig schöner Tag im Internet. So und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht, so sie hat natürlich recht. Wenn ich hier Fake Tweets verbreite, muss ich muss ich dafür die Verantwortung trag.
Also das mit diesem Prinzen, das ist gar nicht echt.
Nee, äh Retweet, weil die Frage ist ja, und ich meine, das ist ja die einzig relevante äh Fake News, die hier im Raume steht.
Ist wissenschaftlich erwiesen, dass die CDU CSU das digitalste Wahlprogramm hat. Und ich mein, wenn ich da Fake Retweet habe.
Dann muss sich dieser dieser Verantwortung ja gerecht werden. Zum Glück habe ich ja hier diesen Podcast, zum Glück habe ich E-Mail, also habe ich den Autoren geschrieben und habe gesagt, können sie mir bitte mal diese Studie schicken? Ähm ich würde mir die gerne mal anschauen, ja? Und,
dazu ein paar Fragen gestellt und äh die wurden mir auch beantwortet. So, jetzt gucken wir mal ganz kurz mh.
Und ich habe auch das äh sage ich äh hier ganz transparent. Das war in schriftlicher Austausch mit den Herrn Sievert und den Herrn König, den beiden Autoren dieser Studie.
Und den habe ich insgesamt wie viele Fragen gestellt ähm acht, neun, neun Fragen
Ähm und daraus hat sich dann noch eine weitere Fachdiskussion äh entsponnen. Und ich habe mit den vereinbart, dass sich jede Frage vollständig und auch jede Antwort vollständig vorlese, weil sie
ähm verständlicherweise äh von der Sorge geprägt sind, dass ihre Studie
in den falschen Kontext gerissen wird. Jetzt muss man erstmal grundsätzlich sagen, was diese Studie gemacht hat, also die Methodik,
dieser Studie ist folgende. Ja, also wie kommt man zu der zu der Aussage, ne ähm irgendeine.
Irgendeine Partei wäre digitaler oder sonst was, ne? Die Aussage übrigens, ob sie die getroffen haben oder nicht, kommen wir gleich drauf. Aber Methodik, also was hat diese Studie gemacht?
Wenn ich das nur kurz äh einwerfen darf, ist ja auch die Frage, was ist eigentlich so die Prämisse, wie ist dieser Begriff eigentlich definiert? Also was verstehen sie, verstehen sie denn eigentlich da drunter?
Genau, also und also ab langer Rede, kurzer Sinn, ich erkläre jetzt hier oder ich zitiere jetzt erstmal hier aus dem Paper, welche Methode haben sie gemacht,
Ähm übrigens, der Titel der Studie ist
Kurz Studie Digitalpolitik der Parteien zur Bundestagswahl zwanzigeinundzwanzig. Ne, da steht nicht drin, welches die digitalste Partei. Ähm zur Methodik. Diese Analyse basiert auf einem systematischen Datensatz auf Bundes und Länderebene,
der alle Wahlprogramme der derzeit im Bundestag vertretenen Parteien seit 2010 umfasst.
Milz einer umfangreichen Liste von 87 Schlagwörtern, zum Beispiel digital, Daten, Industrie vier Punkt null, E-Sport und Upload,
wurden hierzu in einem ersten Schritt relevante Sätze mit Bezug zum Themenfeld,
Digitalisierung aus dem Programm mit Hilfe einer Software gefehlt hat,
Also die haben äh die einzelnen Sätze genommen, hatten 87, die nach denen sie gesucht haben und wenn Sätze.
Eines oder mehrere dieser Buzzwörter äh beinhaltet haben, dann haben sie die genommen.
Dann haben sie gesagt, die so identifizierten Sätze wurden dann in einem zweiten Schritt entlang eines eigens entwickelten Kategorienschemas insgesamt 18 Themenbereichen zugeordnet
Themenbereiche waren dann sowas wie Forschung, Datenschutz, äh Open Data, Open Source, ja? Darüber hinaus gibt es auch eine Kategorie unspezifisch, in die Aussagen mit allgemeinem Charakter,
oder Aussagen, die vielen verschiedenen Themen aneinanderreihen zugeordnet werden
Setze ohne Digitalisierungsbezug wurden aus dem Datensatz entfernt. Parteien auf Bundes und Länder
äh äh entfernt. Insgesamt beinhaltet der Datensatz mehr als 20.000 Sätze zur Digitalpolitik, der derzeit im Bundestag vertretenen Parteien auf Bundes und Länder, Ebene und so weiter, ja? Sagen sie,
Sie haben gezählt in Sätzen, ja? Das ist äh die Analyseeinheit,
die sie jetzt hier tatsächlich zu einer Studie äh aufgeblasen haben und daraus äh Schlüsse ziehen möchten.
Nur um mal zu sagen, was also man, ich denke, die die Grenzen dieser Methode sind ziemlich offensichtlich,
ähm aber äh dazu weiter mehr. Also habe ich den beiden mal geschrieben, sage ich so, er erste Frage, welche Partei hat das digitalste Wahlprogramm? Denn.
Das ist ja das, was äh Dorothee Bär als wissenschaftlich erwiesen ansieht, dass die CDU CSU das digitalste Wahlprogramm hat. Antwort der Autorin der Studie,
Wir nehmen an, diese Frage bezieht sich auf die Kurzüberschrift äh auf die Unterschrift im Tagesspiegelbeitrag, der die Aussage in unserer Kurzanalyse so nicht vorkommt.
Im ersten Teil legen wir da, dass die Bedeutung von Digitalisierung über Zeit gewachsen ist,
Dabei zeigt sich, dass die CDU CSU in ihrem Wahlprogramm 221 in Relation zur länge des Programms.
Am meisten über Digitalisierung spricht. Gefolgt von der FDP und dann SPD. Na also sie sagen, die meisten.
Im Wahlprogramm der CDU CSU finden wir die meisten Sätze in Relation zur Gesamtlänge des Wahlprogrammes, in denen eines oder mehr unserer 87 vorkommt.
Wie wir ausdrücklich schreiben und auch immer betonen, wenn wir in einem Gespräch die Möglichkeit haben, unsere Forschung zu kontextualisieren. Dies erlaubt keine Aussagen über die Sinnhaftigkeit,
tatsächliche Problemlösung oder Machbarkeit in Bezug auf Inhalte oder Maßnahmen.
Dass unsere kleine Studie auf einen Satz dazu reduziert wurde, wie Digitalparteien sind,
ist bedauerlich. Das hätten wir wohl besser antizipieren müssen, indem wir noch deutlicher schreiben, welche Aussagen zulässig sind und welche nicht.
Unsere Auswertung erhalten durchaus mehr Schattierungen und einige Aspekte, die unseres Erachtens wesentlich spannender und informativer sind, als das bloße Ausmaß, in dem Parteien über digitale schreiben, was eben, wie wir schreiben,
mehr Kontext und qualitative Aufarbeitung erfordert. Ähm,
Kurz ergänzend, was er, was er meint mit äh die spannenden äh informativeren Aspekte äh ist zum Beispiel,
diese Frage in der Reden die jetzt mehr oder weniger über Datenschutz? Ne? Reden die mehr oder weniger über Bildung und Forschung ja? Und dann können sie ja auch sie können ja offenbar auch historisch vergleichen, weil ihr Datensatz ja
wenn ich das richtig erinnere, bis 2010 zurückgeht, ja? Das ist die, das ist die Stellungnahme der Autoren, also,
jetzt offen wahre, ernst gemeinte Entschuldigung an Dorothee Bär. Es stimmt,
nämlich die Aussage, dass wissenschaftlich belegt sei die CDU habe das digitalste Wahlprogramm, ist 'ne fake Aussage ich hoffe, dass ich das jetzt hier mit dem ausführlichen Statement der Autoren,
ausreichend wieder gut gemacht habe, dass ich diesen habe.
Muss ich, ja, du, Tim, da muss man auch einfach mal ehrlich in den Spiegel gucken und sagen, sowas, so ein Quatsch darfst du halt nicht verbreiten,
das kannst du nicht machen. So, ich habe aber noch äh weiter äh mit den Autoren dann äh äh,
gestritten, denn ähm jetzt äh bin ich mal etwas diplomatisch. Diese Studie ähm ist nicht äh
ordentlich dokumentiert
ja? Ähm die war auch am Anfang dieses Tages nicht veröffentlicht und wurde dann äh wurde so auf der Seite der Universität angekündigt, dass sie in den nächsten Tagen veröffentlicht wird mit anderen Worten, die war noch nicht fertig
ja? Und äh das sieht man dann auch in dieser Veröffentlichung, weil da halt zum Beispiel also das ist eine Abbildung, ja.
Abbildung eins, Wichtigkeit von Digitalpolitik im Parteivergleich, Bundestagswahl 1317 2ein.
So bald ein Diagramme, ja? Und in diesem Balkendiagramm ist jetzt die Wichtigkeit von Digitalpolitik abgetragen.
Und die Wichtigkeit ist hier abgetragen auf einer Skala, die geht offenbar also der höchste Wert ist irgendwo über zehn. Da steht aber keine Einheit dran.
So, steht keine Einheit dran. Sondern habe ich gesagt, äh okay, ähm können sie mir bitte sagen, was das Maß der Wichtigkeit ist, ne, worin haben sie denn hier ähm Wichtigkeit.
Also was ist die Einheit, ja? Und ähm in der Fußnote eins steht die äh also der Anteil berechnet sich Zahl der Sätze mit digitalisierungsbezug durch Zahl der Sätze im Wahlprogramm insgesamt. Aber wenn man das macht,
kann ich ja höchstens auf den Wert eins kommen. Ja, in mit anderen Worten, sie haben hier vergessen zu erwähnen, dass sie das nochmal mit 1hundert multiplizieren,
und natürlich 'ne Prozentangabe machen, aber das ich mein
Sorry, wenn du was veröffentlichst als Wissenschaftler, da kannst du nicht eine eine Grafik machen, in der nicht die Einheit benannt ist. Und und die Formel für die Einheit sogar noch falsch äh drin steht, ja. Ähm na ja, mit dieser Frage habe ich den Eindruck bekommen,
haben sie dann auch gemerkt, dass sie mit jemandem zu tun haben, der genau hinguckt, entsprechend lang wurden auch die Antworten.
Ähm
weil bei der, bei der zweiten Tabelle haben sie ebenso einfach eine Prozentangabe, aber keine Bezugsmenge. Ja, also wir sagen dann, äh Top fünf Themen anhand der durchschnittlichen Themen Wichtigkeit über Parteien. Das sind Prozentangaben.
Wo ich dann auch sage, okay, was ist äh
Könnt ihr bitte äh sagen, Prozent wovon, ja, also das ist einfach nicht nicht ordentlich äh erläutert. Ähm.
Gewesen. So, aber kommen wir mal, äh ich gucke jetzt mal gerade ganz kurz, welche Frage noch wirklich interessant war. Ähm.
Die dritte Frage war haben Sie das bisherige Wirken der untersuchten Parteien berücksichtigt und zwar A.
Im Bereich der Digitalpolitik und B unter Berücksichtigung tatsächlicher Umsetzung vergangener Wahlversprechen. Das wäre jetzt bei der CDU durchaus relevant, ne? Also wenn wenn sich die CDU als die digitalste Partei herausstellen würde, ja,
dann müssten wir ja anerkennen, dass die Situation, in der sich die Bundesrepublik Deutschland im Moment in der Digitalpolitik befindet, immer noch die bestmögliche ist
weil wir ja die digitalste Partei an der Regierung haben. Ich gehe davon aus, dass dass wir hier noch das ein oder andere ähm Potential.
Bergen könnten, ja? Antwort, das ist eine wichtige Frage und die kurze darauf
Antwort darauf ist, nein. Das haben wir nicht. Wir planen gerade hier für Forschungsgelder einzuwerben, die genau dies macht. Unsere Analyse sagt somit nichts darüber aus, wie
inkompetent oder kompetent die Parteien im Bereich Digitalpolitik aufgestellt sind oder wie erfolgreich Regierungsparteien bei der Umsetzung ihrer
sprechen in Bezug auf die Digitalisierung sind. Gerade letzteres ist mit einem massiven Rechercheaufwand verbunden aber ist natürlich zentral um die Regierungsleistung von Politikerinnen bewerten zu können,
So etwas wie sie mit ihrer Frage ansprechen, machen wir in einem Beitrag zur grün-schwarzen Regierung in Baden-Württemberg Kretschmer zwei, der gerade im Erscheinen ist. Hier untersuchen wir, was die Parteien in in den Wahlprogrammen versprechen
Was im Koalitionsvertrag vorkommt und was dann im Bereich Ausbau digitaler Infrastruktur und E-Government tatsächlich umgesetzt wurde.
Die Kurzfassung, es ist natürlich nicht alles Gold, was Gold, was glänzt und beileibe wird nicht alles gehalten, was im Wahlprogramm versprochen wird. Ähm.
Vor allem denke ich, sollte man auch nochmal äh ihnen
Also bei allen handelwerklichen Fehlern, die sie jetzt hier offensichtlich begangen haben, ja und auch der Fehleinschätzung, der Wahrnehmung einer solchen Kurzstudie eben der Hektik äh der heutigen Zeit
und des Wahlkampfs, ja äh,
Das war jetzt sicherlich kein, kein besonders kluger Move und ich denke, die haben haben einfach die Situation komplett unterschätzt und dann waren sie auch nicht äh stringent genug. Aber die,
Auswertung, die sie ja am Anfang sagen, drei Punkte, ne, dass sie eigentlich nur aus der aus dieser Analyse der Daten herauslesen, A, dass die Bedeutung des Themas seit der Wahl im Jahr 2013 deutlich zugenommen hat.
Okay? Ja, B, klare Verschiebung bei den wichtigsten digitalpolitischen Themen stattgefunden haben,
gut und äh drittens hier C, sich die Partei zur Bundestagswahl 21 bei ihren digitalpolitischen Schwerpunktsetzungen zwar unterscheiden, allerdings auch ein gemeinsamer Kern von Priorisierten besteht.
Okay, äh habt ihr aber richtig tief reingeschaut so. Das hätte ich euch aber auch ohne Studie sagen können.
Gott, ey.
Das ist nämlich genau der Gag, ja, also klar, die haben jetzt eine Analysemethodik und das ist.
Genau, das das ist Wordcount und äh ja, man muss also man kann ja in der Wissenschaft alles Mögliche messen. Und.
Ob das, was man misst, also,
ein, eine wirklich auch eine relevante Entsprechung hat. Das ist die Frage, ja? Und das limitiert natürlich auch die Aussagekraft. Die Aussagekraft dieser Studie ist im Prinzip sie können nur.
Aussagen treffen über die Häufigkeit von Sätzen, in denen bestimmte Worte vorkommen, ja? Die Störgrößen sind völlig klar. Es kann sein, dass Leute, äh, dass in einigen Wahlprogrammen, äh, auch einfach,
klarere Forderungen definiert werden, so dass die mit mit wenigeren Sätzen auskommen, ja? Es kann äh sein, dass.
Mit ihren 87 sie nicht jeden Satz über Digitalisierung erfassen, weil
gehe jetzt mal zum Beispiel davon aus, vielleicht jetzt eine Linkspartei sich äh über Arbeitsmarkt und Digitalisierung Gedanken macht, einen Satz Digitalisierung schreibt und danach von mir aus 25 Sätze über äh wie die wie die
wie die Arbeitswelt anders gestaltet werden muss, in Anbetracht der Digitalisierung, ja? Und dass
hier eine fundierte Auseinandersetzung mit äh zentralen Themen äh des des politischen Miteinanders stattfindet, während äh die CDU so etwas sagt wie wir brauchen eine Blockchain-Strategie und dafür den gleichen Punkt kriegt.
Also diese Methodik ist ja äh weil sie die Semantik vollständig ignoriert ähm,
relativ eingeschränkt. Ähm deswegen habe ich äh denen die Frage gestellt.
Ähm worin sehen sie wissenschaftliche Grenzen ihrer Methodik hinsichtlich Erfassungsmethode, Validität und Aussagekraft und Valität und Aussagekraft ist das Entscheidende, weil ich kann alles messen, aber ich muss,
Wenn ich sage, das ist jetzt eine Studie und die hat jetzt irgendetwas belegt,
Ja oder irgendeinen Zusammenhang hergestellt, dann brauche ich eine Korrelation zu einem Außenkriterium, ja, dass ich Vorhersagen möchte. Und ähm es könnte zum Beispiel äh.
Also ne? Klassisches Ding ist Intelligenztests werden so gebaut, dass sie Schulnoten vorhersagen
Ja, nur als Beispiel, was man versucht zu machen. Das ist ähm nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht gut, weil weil man eben Intelligenz leider nicht,
messen kann, ne? Genauso kann man vielleicht äh Digitalisierungspolitik.
Nicht direkt messen, zumindest nicht, wenn man äh als einziges Werkzeug ein Wortzähler äh hat. Ähm Antwort,
Wir denken, dass wir die Grenzen des gewählten Ansatzes hinreichend in der Studie dargelegt haben. Wir wollen aber betonen, dass der von uns gewählter Ansatz ein bewährtes Standardverfahren politikwissenschaftlicher Forschung zu Partei, Parteienwettbewerb und Parteiensystem,
Wir haben hierzu mit unseren Daten auch in blind begutachteten Fachzeitschriften publiziert. Andere Verfahren, die derzeit in sind, wie etwa reine Auszählungen von Worten, besitzen eine ähnliche
eher aber sogar geringere Aussagekraft, weil die semantische
weil der semantische Kontext von Sätzen verloren gehen kann. Qualitative Betrachtungen der Wahlprogramme, wie sie derzeit überall zu finden sind, haben den Vorteil, direkt
die Aussagen offen darlegen zu können, haben aber dann den Nachteil, dass sie in der Regel unsystematisch sind. So etwas,
wie eine Abschätzung der relativen Gewichte sind in anderen Darstellungen nach unserem Wissen bislang.
Zu finden gewesen. So, jetzt muss ich, weil ich's versprochen habe, die gesamte Antwort vorlesen. Was können wir sagen? Erstens, wie sich die Bedeutung Wichtigkeit,
welche Parteien,
dem Thema Digitalisierung zuschreiben, entwickelt, beziehungsweise entwickelt hat ausgehend, etablierter Theorien sagt, die Häufigkeit, wie oft ein Thema in einem Wahlprogramm genannt wird.
Darüber aus, wie bedeutsam es für die Partei ist.
Gemäß Politikwissenschaftlicher Annahmen zu den Motiven von Parteien im politischen Wettbewerb ist davon auszugehen, dass eine größere Betonung heißt, die Partei denkt damit Wählerinnen Stimmen gewinnen zu können, sonst würde sie den Platz im Wahlprogramm für etwas anderes aufwenden.
Soweit stimmt Captain, ob wir es auch zu.
Zweitens kommen die zentralen inhaltlichen Aussagen dann im Abschnitt zwei und drei der Studie. Hier zeigt sich eine deutliche Schwerpunktverlagerung der Themenfelder welche über die Parteien sprechen
Über welche die Parteien sprechen. Wie wir darlegen, werden ökonomische Themen wichtiger, ebenso Bildung und Forschung und 2021 eben auch das Thema Sicherheitsthemen, das heißt Cyber-Sicherheit, innere Sicherheit, wie Speicherung, Videoüberwachung et cetera, Cyberkriminalität.
Auch Hate Speech sind über die Zeit konstant wichtig,
Gleichzeitig haben andere Themen der Digitalpolitik massiv an Aufmerksamkeit, das heißt an Wichtigkeit, die Parteien in einem Themenfeld zuweisen
abgenommen. Dies zeigt sich vor allem beim Thema Privatsphäre und Datenschutz oder dem Thema gleicher und ilalitärer Zugang,
Digitalisierung. Drittens dürfte jenseits des Tweets von Frau Staatsministerin Bea, interessant sein, dass erstens manche Themen aus der politischen Öffentlichkeit zu verschwinden scheinen. Und zweitens, Digitalisierung in manchen
Themenfeldern von Parteien praktisch überhaupt nicht aufgegriffen werden. Hierauf gehen wir in Abschnitt drei ein. So, jetzt mal ein kleines Beispiel,
Für warum ein solcher Ansatz wirklich hinkt, ja? Und der schreibt es hier auch und merkt es noch nicht mal. Er sagt.
Themen der Digitalpolitik haben massiv an Aufmerksamkeit verloren und benennt Datenschutz als Beispiel, ja?
Wir haben jetzt eine Datenschutzgrundverordnung. Das ist ein Themenbereich, der politisch behandelt wurde. Ja, und es ist zu erwarten, dass vor vier Jahren,
als die Thema DSGVO hochdiskutiert wurde, die Parteien sich natürlich auch dazu positioniert haben.
Mit dem Inkrafttreten äh jetzt dieses Thema natürlich von der politischen Agenda äh,
geht, ja? Diese gesamte Analyse, die diese Leute hier gemacht haben, geht ja irgendwie davon aus, dass es kein politisches Geschehen oder Vorankommen gäbe.
Also es ist die tatsächlich werden ja äh Themen behandelt, umgesetzt, ja und ähm tatsächlich ändert sich ja auch das, wozu Politik sich verhalten muss. Ja und,
dieser, das scheint mir die größte Störgröße zu sein, ähm wenn man jetzt sagt, das ist das Wahlprogramm von vor vier Jahren.
Das ist das Wahlprogramm von jetzt, die legen auf einmal gar keinen Wert mehr auf, was weiß ich, Arbeitsmarkt oder so, ja?
Eventuell, weil eine große Arbeitsmarktreform verabschiedet wurde und eventuell, weil äh eine Wirtschaftskrise war oder nicht war. Ja, also das ist es gibt ja auch Außenfaktoren.
Und auf die reagieren ja diese Parteiprogramme. Und das, das scheint denen überhaupt nicht scheinen die nicht auf dem Schirm zu haben, ja?
Und dann gab es aber noch und da da war ich da muss ich sagen, da lag ich dann wirklich äh ein bisschen unterm Tisch. Äh da war dann meine Frage, äh,
die die erübrigt sich, ja, diese Frage äh habe ich geschrieben
bevor ich die, nee, dir, da hatte ich die Studie auch, aber egal. Ich also die Frage ist dumm von mir, ja, haben sie für die unterschiedliche Länge der Wahlprogramme kontrolliert? Ja, haben sie, weil sie haben ja Anteil Sätze an
gesamt Anzahlsätzen genommen. Also die Frage erübrigt sich in entsprechend äh antworten sie auch sehr diplomatisch. Das ist eine essenzielle, methodische Frage. Es ist unerlässlich die Länge der Programme zu berücksichtigen, um Vergleichbarkeit herzustellen und sinnvolle Aussagen treffen zu können.
Bei längeren Parteiprogramm vor allem Grüne und Linke ist die Grundwahrscheinlichkeit höher, dass Themen mehr
Platz einnehmen als bei kürzeren. Daher ist das unbedingt zu kontrollieren. Die Fußnote eins, ja, genau die, wo sie falsch erklären, was ihr Maß ist, zeigt,
wir die Aussagen normiert haben, wir teilen die Zahl identifizierter, relevanter Sätze mit Digitalisierungsbezug durch die Gesamtzahl aller Sätze im Wahlprogramm ohne Teile wie Inhaltsverzeichnis, glossar und so weiter, versteht sich nur Haupttext, ja? So.
Jetzt kommt der Teil, wo ich, also da will ich dann wirklich auch hinten runtergefallen, ne. Ich schreibe hier mit zwei Wissenschaftlern ähm die eine wissenschaftliche Studie veröffentlicht haben.
Im Namen der äh was war das? TU München und Uni Kaiserslautern, ja? Und die gerade in den Medien ähm.
Diskutiert und zitiert wird.
Jetzt schreiben die mir, wir wissen von zumindest einem, ebenfalls auf Twitter zu findenden Berechnung der absoluten Zeichen,
Anzahl von Textstellen mit Digitalisierungsbezug in den Programm. Falls Sie diesen gesehen haben, hier der nicht gesehen haben, hier der Link. Ist ein Link auf ein Tweet, ja? So.
Abgesehen darf, also hier hat jemand äh Max Mut, ja, Journalist, ähm Bayerischer Rundfunk, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Und er hat im Prinzip mit so einem Google.
Die Analyse nicht Wörter auf Sätze, sondern ähm.
Zeichen, Zahl und Textstellen genommen, ja, was natürlich das Gleiche ist, ja? Ab und jetzt sagen die Autoren der Studie, abgesehen davon, dass durch das Zählen der Zeichen, die durchschnittliche Wortlänge der Programme nicht berücksichtigt wird, und er schlägt die,
absolute Häufigkeit, auch die Gesamtlänge der Programme. Wir haben geschaut, was passiert, wenn man die Zeichen
Zahl ins Verhältnis mit der Gesamtlänge setzt. Das Ergebnis liefert ziemlich genau die Parteiunterschiede, die wir in den Sätzen herausbekommen.
Und jetzt kommt der, jetzt kommt der Punkt,
Spannend ist das gerade auch mit Blick auf ihre Frage zwei, da dies die Validität unserer Analyse stärkt. Auf Basis eines anderen Datensatzes kommt man zu ähnlichen Ergebnissen. So und da habe ich, da bin ich hinten untergefallen, weil das ist der gleiche Datensatz, nämlich,
der diese Wahlprogramme die analysiert hat. Er hatte irgendwie auf Zeichenebene getan, sie haben es auf,
auf Wortebene getan und jetzt sagen sie, das hätte ihre Analyse, in ihrer Qualität, Valität bestärkt. So, Validität heißt aber, dass das, was sie, was sie gemessen haben, eine Aussage, also eine eine äh Korrelation,
mit einem Außenkriterium hat. Ja und zwar einem, dass ihr Konstrukt.
Bestätigt. Ja, also würden sie zum Beispiel so etwas machen wie, okay, wir haben uns die Wahlprogramme angeschaut, der Bundesländer und wir haben jetzt festgestellt, da wo mehr digital im Wahlprogramm steht,
ist auch irgendwie mehr digital, da ist der Breitbandausbau besser oder irgendetwas, ja? Oder da wird mehr in der Schule über digitales gerechnet und die die Kompetenz der Schülerinnen im im Digitalbereich ist größer. Das wäre Validität, weil sie dann nämlich ein relevantes Außenkriterium hätten
mit denen äh mit der sie,
mit dem sie hier eine Korrelation herstellen. Also habe ich denen geantwortet, entschuldigen sie bitte an dieser Stelle eine unmittelbare methodische Korrektur. Was sie hier vermutlich meinen, ist die Reliabilität.
Die Validität,
Sie haben nicht einen anderen Datensatz verwendet, sondern den gleichen Datensatz mit einer minimal anderen Analysemethode zugeführt. Es ist unmittelbar offensichtlich, dass diese minimal andere Analysemethode nicht
nennenswert unterschiedlichen Ergebnissen führen kann. Insofern ist die Probe auch nicht zur Erfassung der Rediabilität geeignet, sondern einfach gar nichts.
Und dann wurd's halt lustig, jetzt wird's auch wirklich nur noch äh wissenschaftliches ähm,
wissenschaftliches Batteln, dann hat er mir äh validität erklärt, wie sie in Sozialwissenschaften und Psychologie verwendet wird.
Wenn man meinen Namen googelt, findet man nicht sofort, dass ich ein paar Jahre psychologische Methoden lehre, unterrichtet habe,
Insofern ähm habe ich ihn dann nochmal kurz erklärt, ähm dass
Kriteriumsqualität bedeutet, dass Messung mit einer anderen validen Messung korrelieren, Qualität bedeutet, dass Messung, das erfassen, was sie erfassen sollen und dass hier bei ihnen ein Zirkelschluss vorliegt, wenn sie meinen,
dass ihre Studie in ihrer Validität bestärkt wird, weil irgendjemand ein Google Dog getwittert hat, in dem was Ähnliches rauskommt, ja?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich davon halten soll. Ich also die Studie ist wirklich schwach. Das muss man ganz einfach mal sagen,
fehler fehlerhaft in der in der Beschreibung der Methoden. Ähm allerdings muss man sagen, dass sie schon in der äh in der ähm.
Also die Fehlinterpretation dieser Studie äh liegen nicht bei den Autoren, sondern,
bei denen, die es nachher betrachtet haben. Ja, also hier steht nirgendwo äh irgendwie was weiß ich so etwas, wie die CDU CSU, wer hätte das digitalste Programm, ne? Die haben schon äh die Grenzen ihrer Methode
denke ich durchaus verstanden. Sie überschätzen die natürlich trotzdem, aber sie sind sich dessen bewusst, welche Aussage sie treffen können und welche nicht.
Und äh sie machen auch spezifisch ähm in der, in der äh in dem.
Teil drei äh Parteiunterschiede, machen sie halt äh die Schwerpunktthemen und sagen, okay, die eine Partei hat äh mehr,
mehr Sätze zu folgendem Themenbereich und die andere zu diesem anderen, ne? Das war diese Kategorisierung, wo sie dann die einzelnen Sätze äh kategorisiert haben.
Also ich ich kann mir förmlich vorstellen, wie die schon das Flattern bekommen haben, als du irgendwie mit deiner E-Mail ankamst, so und ihre Antwort würde ich jetzt einfach mal frei übersetzen mit
Wir wollen diese Aufmerksamkeit nicht äh bitte weitergehen, es ist nichts geschehen. Äh wir wissen ja selber, dass das alles Unfug ist und ähm.
Auch nochmal zu Dorothee Bär und und überhaupt jetzt also erstens, diese Schlussfolgerung,
steht da natürlich nicht drin. Das haben wir jetzt ausführlich dargelegt so, ja?
Selbst wenn da auch irgendwas drin wäre, muss ich einfach jetzt auch mal sehr genau sein und sagen, digital.
Ist einfach ein Wort, das nicht steigerungsfähig. Digital ist man oder nicht, aber es gibt nichts, was,
Genau, also digitaler und digitalst äh könnt ihr einfach mal komplett aus eurem Wortschatz äh streichen, ja? Das, das, das ist so ein bisschen wie einzigste. Und ähm.
Das zeigt einfach nur, wie auch bekloppt aufgeladen dieses Wort ist,
ich weiß nicht, kennst du wahrscheinlich, ist so ein bisschen mein, ne, irgendwie, also Leute, die wirklich viel mit Computern zu tun haben oder überhaupt irgendwelche Leute heutzutage, äh benutzen ja alle dieses Wort. Aber frag mal irgendjemanden mal, was es überhaupt heißt.
Es weiß keiner. Keiner kann das erklären. Keiner kann erklären, was digital ist und da steige ich meistens dann auch schon aus und es ist,
Absurd. Ich habe meinen Podcast äh dazu gemacht irgendwie, wo ich mich mal bemüht habe, das mal herzuleiten. Aber ganz unabhängig davon.
CDU ist überhaupt nichts digital,
seid einfach mal sowas von äh also es ist so ich will jetzt nicht so so ein Bashing gehen, aber das ist etwas, was mich
Auch nicht nur an der CDU stört. Das stört mich an Deutschland an sich und es macht sich halt in diesem Parteienspektrum übrigens auch bei den Grünen.
Immer wieder deutlich, ja? Dass man einfach das Wesen dessen, was die Digitalisierung an Chancen und Risiken,
Einfach nicht erfasst oder bestenfalls nur im Ansatz. So, weil man sich einfach
gar nicht auf die richtige Art und Weise damit beschäftigt und dann irgendwie rumzuprallen, dass man ja irgendwie es geschafft hat, noch mal mehr auf äh Apfel V äh zu drücken im Wahlprogramm, wo dann nochmal irgendwie die ganzen wiedergegeben werden und der Wordcount schlägt dann irgendwie an, irgendwelche dahergelaufenen Wissenschaftler
geben dann Studien auch noch über so einen Quatsch raus. Wo womit beschäftigt ihr euch eigentlich?
Wofür verwendet ihr eure Zeit mit so einem Unsinn? Leute, echt?
Es ist, es ist tatsächlich und
jetzt möchte ich nochmal, also ich habe ja jetzt ein bisschen äh hier die die Studie von äh Herrn König und Herrn Sievert ein bisschen sitziert, ja? Natürlich auch unter die hat natürlich eine ungerechtfertigte Aufmerksamkeit bekommen von mir jetzt, weil ich
äh mir jetzt die Mühe gemacht habe, eine Fake News von Doro Bär zu zerlegen. Und die kann ich halt nur zerlegen, indem ich auch eine methodische Kritik an dem an diesem äh Paper.
Hinterlege. Äh äh hinterlasse und dummerweise hatten die halt Angriffsfläche. Das war halt keine kluge
Idee, eine unfertige Studie erstmal dem Tagespiegel zu erzählen, ja? Und irgendwelchen Leuten, die dann auf Twitter sich darüber zanken, wer wen verarscht, ne? Aber überleg dir mal bitte, was hier passiert ist. Hier hast du eine.
Staatsministerin im Bundeskanzleramt für Digitalisierung, die.
Spezifisch sagt, die die Behauptung aufstellt, etwas wäre wissenschaftlich erwiesen und die Autoren der Studie widersprechen explizit unmittelbar und sofort und sehr streng, dass das nicht die Aussage ihrer Studie ist.
Und dient sich dann noch weiter äh irgendwie die Blöße gibt,
mich dann irgendwie das Verbreitens von Fake äh Tweets zu bezichtigen, nur weil sie eine Unwahrheit in die Welt gesetzt hat, ja? Und ähm gleichzeitig auch.
Möchte ich jetzt mal einen anderen Bogen ausspannen, um hier auch noch mal, wie gesagt, die Forscher zu zu schützen.
Die haben ja eine Methode, diese Methode ist sicherlich sehr interessant und man hat ähm in der Forschung natürlich eine Tendenz sich über Methoden zu freuen,
die schön sauber funktionieren und mit relativ wenig Aufwand, ja? Also
eine semantische Analyse wäre sehr viel aufwendiger gewesen, ne? Und sie haben jetzt hier einfach, ne, ein kleines Skript, zählt zählt Wörter, ne, das kannst du in Pfeifen äh schreiben in, in, in sehr kurzer Zeit und kannst schöne Grafiken machen und,
kannst ähm,
kannst damit Veröffentlichungen machen ja? Und dann sagt man oh krass hier die haben Parteienforschung und dann legt man das Ergebnis mal so hin und dann solche Ergebnisse sind ja die Studie muss ja nicht alles,
haben. Es kann ja zum Beispiel sein, dass dass diese ähm diese äh Mengen, diese Worthäufigkeiten, die sie da jetzt gemessen haben,
in Zukunft ähm eine sehr starke ähm Vorhersagekraft zeigen, dass man jetzt irgendwie feststellt, okay, die die,
die die sagen vorher, ob eine Partei gewählt wird oder die haben am Ende stellen die sogar fest, dass das dass die Parteien das sogar umsetzen, äh was sie, äh was sie im Wahlprogramm stehen haben, äh Klammer auf werden sie nicht feststellen können, also dass
da wird er ja auch das ist ja klar, dass sie es nicht umsetzen, aber.
Wir haben jetzt äh seit anderthalb Jahren eine Pandemie. Wir haben Forscherinnen und Forscher, die an diesem Virus.
Forschen und die veröffentlichen ihre Studien und kauen Fingernägel, dass nicht irgendeine Inkompetente Hohlbratze, die Überschrift falsch versteht,
und das Opferbild Zeitung Seite eins ballert. Ja ähm und denkt mal an so Situationen, ich meine das ist ja jetzt hier noch irrelevant, das ist eine Wahlkampf.
Unwahre Behauptung von Dorothee Bär und ich will noch nicht mal eine böse Absicht unterstellen, weil vielleicht unterschätze ich sie jetzt wieder, aber ehrlich gesagt glaube ich nicht, dass sie die Studie gelesen hat.
Zumindest nicht zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie diesen Tweet veröffentlicht hat. Ja? Äh die gab es ja auch noch nicht und insofern halte ich es, glaube ich, die hat einfach Tagesspiegel gelesen, hat gesagt, geil, wir sind wissenschaftlich die digitalsten und und dann hat dies was anderes gemacht,
Ich weiß nicht, was die Frau macht. Also Digitalpolitik ja nicht, aber ähm so.
So passieren diese Dinge und ich ich muss hier wirklich mal für die für die Forschung echt mal leiden, dass die dass.
Dass ihre, dass sie ja Angst haben müssen, ihre Ergebnisse zu veröffentlichen.
Weil sie Angst haben müssen nachher in in falsche Kontexte gerissen zu werden. Und hier ist das noch relativ irrelevant, aber im im Kontext einer, einer Pandemie,
ist es sehr fatal, ja? Sehr schön, was ja gerade diskutiert wird, ist.
Dieses wunderschöne äh äh Fehler, das also es gibt Menschen, die sind geimpft und die infizieren sich dennoch mit dem äh Coronavirus.
Und von diesen Menschen gibt es welche, die dann auch auf dem, auf der Intensivstation landen.
Und wenn du wenn du jetzt, ich einfache Rechnung, sagen wir mal die Impfung schützt in 90 Prozent der Fälle gegen eine Infektion, ne, dann heißt das,
90, also du hast diese ganzen Geimpften,
Von denen werden jetzt die haben zehn Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit infiziert zu werden in Situationen, wo Ungeimpfte 1hundert Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit hätten, ja?
Wie gesagt, gibt ja keine hundert Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit. Also sie haben nur 90 Prozent, sie haben nur zehn Prozent der Wahrscheinlichkeit, die Ungeimpfte haben. So und jetzt gehst du hin und gehst in eine Intensivstation.
Und guck's dir an, die Patienten, die da liegen und wenn du jetzt folgende Messung machst,
Wie viele von denen sind geimpft? Dann wirst du feststellen, dass mit der Zeit der Anteil geimpfter Patienten auf der Intensivstation zunimmt.
Wenn du diese Zahl jetzt veröffentlichen würdest, ohne dir darüber Gedanken zu machen, sagst du, äh die Geimpften äh haben keinen Schutz, die Intensivstationen laufen nämlich jetzt immer voller und wenn das so weitergeht, liegen da irgendwann nur noch Geimpfte.
So, der Hintergrund ist aber, du hast inzwischen mehr Geimpfte als Ungeimpfte.
Ja? Und das es ist natürlich klar, dass damit der Anteil der Geimpften, bei denen die trotz der Impfung eine Infektion ausbricht,
langsam zunimmt. Irgendwann wirst du hoffentlich nur noch Geimpfte und Genesene haben, die sich trotzdem am laufenden Band mit Corona infizieren. Das wäre also genauso wie zu sagen, ähm diesen schönen Vergleich habe ich auf Twitter gelesen. Ähm.
Es gibt Menschen, die tragen einen Gurt und bauen trotzdem Unfälle, bei denen sie sterben.
Ja, stimmt, Leute mit Anschnallgurt sterben in Situationen, in denen Menschen ohne Anschnallgurt garantiert gestorben wären. Und.
Also sorry für dieses ausholende Beispiel, aber wissenschaftlicher ist wissenschaft ist halt wirklich ein komplexes Themenfeld und das lässt sich nicht von irgendwelchen äh Journalisten,
Die sich damit auseinandersetzen, wer genau wen auf Twitter verarscht hat, äh akzeptabel in ihrem Inhalt äh äh,
würdigen können. Diese Studie gehört einfach nicht in eine in eine Medienöffentlichkeit. Diese Studie gehört in irgendwie in Methoden äh in den Methodendiskussionen von irgendwelchen Politikwissenschaftlern, die sagen können, okay, wir haben diese Methode, wo sind ihre Grenzen, was können wir erkennen?
Stellen wir vielleicht irgendwelche Korrelationen mit was anderem dar, bringen wir hier unser Feld voran, wenn wir das machen
ja? Meine Schätzung ist nein, aber äh die dürfen ja machen, was sie wollen. Und offensichtlich hat ihnen das auch jemand ähm finanziert. Aber wenn wir dann wirklich von von Vollidioten äh auf Twitter diese solche Studien diskutieren lassen,
dann dann ist doch niemandem geholfen.
Also ich habe jetzt verstanden, dass wenn's jetzt keiner wenn keine Leute mehr im Verkehr äh sterben, können wir die Gurtpflicht abschaffen.
Genau.
Da passiert ja nichts mehr.
Also abschließend nochmal hier an Herrn König und Herrn Sievert. Äh meine Einschätzung zu den zu der Aussagekraft der Studie.
Habe ich ja mitgeteilt und sehe da jetzt auch in unserer fachlichen Diskussion eigentlich wenig Unterschied und es
ähm äh dass dass sie ihre Studie überinterpretieren würden. Ähm es tut mir natürlich leid, dass die ähm,
dass ihnen das Miss das das Unglück passiert ist, dass Dorothee Bär eine Lüge über ihre Studie veröffentlicht hat. Sorry, ist keine Lüge, eine Unwahrheit. Äh ähm,
über ihre Studie verbreitet hat. Und ich das retweetet habe, dafür muss ich mich auch entschuldig.
Ja und noch so viel Unsinn dazu erfunden hast.
Oh Mann, ey. Na ja, okay, so viel äh zur zur Forschung, aber.
Problem, wenn wenn dir dann der Prinz aus Nigeria das Geld überwiesen hat, kannst du ja einfach den Anteil schicken.
Stimmt, wenn sie das Geld nicht haben will, nehme ich das.
Tja, ja. Es ist so schwierig, mal mit dieser ganzen Wahl.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ich weiß gar nicht, äh ich bin schon vollkommen verwirrt.
Ja, Tim.
Du weißt ja, ne? Ich bin erst.
Erstwähler. Das ist äh das ist ein äh ein weit umkämpftes Feld. Ich glaube, die CDU CSU hat dieses Feld äh glaube ich äh kampflos äh.
Aufgegeben. Die anderen auch.
Aber ja, Tim ist Erstwähl.
Also zumindest, was die Bundestagswahl betrifft und nur, was die Bundestagswahl, nee, stimmt nicht, was die Bundestags- und die Landtagswahl betrifft, bin ich jetzt Erstwähler.
Oje, vielleicht sollte man das kurz erklären, du bist erst weder weil.
Weil ich äh vor vier Jahren noch keine deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit besessen habe offiziell. Die habe ich mittlerweile.
Und dementsprechend qualifiziere ich jetzt auch für die Landtagswahl und die Bundestagswahl.
Oder mal anders ausgedrückt, als EU-Mitglied stand es mir nicht frei, äh obwohl ich quasi mein ganzes Leben in Deutschland lebe, äh diesen politischen Prozess einer Landtagswahl.
Geschweige denn in der Bundestagswahl. Ähm,
aktiv mitzugestalten in irgendeiner Form. Also ich hätte mich wahrscheinlich als Wahlhelfer melden können so, aber abstimmen äh wäre halt jetzt irgendwie wahrscheinlich nicht dran gewesen. Deswegen hat die auch keinen Bock Wahlhelfer zu sein, ehrlich zu sein.
Nee, das wäre ja blöd, also das äh Wahlhelfer uns selber nicht wählen zu dürfen, ist ja keine Ahnung. Für was, was.
Trotzdem habe ich mich, habe ich mich schon ein paar Mal.
Im Steakhouse arbeiten. Ist halt auch.
Aber ich habe mir auch schon ein paar mal in den Wahlprozess äh mit eingebracht hier erinnert mich da noch, als wir irgendwie die ganzen,
Wahllokale abgeklappert haben als irgendwie die ganze ProH, um die Wahlcomputer lief. Na ja, egal, aber ich könnte jetzt mal eine Empfehlung gebrauchen und wir dachten, man könnte ja jetzt mal so ein bisschen über die Bundestagswahl,
ähm sinnieren, was denn eigentlich so die Themen sind.
Die einen jetzt äh leiten könnten. Ich meine klar, jeder hat natürlich so seine Partikularinteressen und je nachdem, welcher Branche man arbeitet oder in welchem Feld man forscht oder sonst wie seine Interessen und Hobbys hat, gibt's dann immer wieder nochmal so Dinge, aber es gibt ja dann auch wie
großen Rahmendaten und natürlich bei uns äh spezifisch auch diese politische Perspektive. Ne.
Ja. Was soll ich also hast du und jetzt soll ich dich beraten, wen du wählen sollst?
Also es ist ja jetzt so tatsächlich also ein ein Unterschied, den ich jetzt äh schon festgestellt habe, ist, während ich also früher, ich habe mir immer den Spaß gemacht und habe eigentlich immer zu jeder Wahl.
Ähm für mich entschlossen, was ich wählen würde. Ich konnte es dann nicht tun, aber ich habe die Wahlen nicht ignoriert, sondern ich habe eigentlich immer eine klare.
Wahl getroffen für mich, was ich wählen würde.
So wie wie beim Lotto.
Meine Zahlen.
Schon wieder.
Äh
und merke aber trotzdem, dass in dem Moment, wo man's dann auch wirklich kann, es dann sich doch nochmal ein bisschen anders anfühlt und ich ein bisschen mehr Verständnis für Leute habe, die ähm sagen.
Ah ich kann mich da nicht entscheiden oder das fällt mir schwer oder oder so, weil es ist ja immer einfacher für Leute irgendwie eine Wahl, also eine eine Maßnahme quasi zu beschließen, die man nicht selber durchführen muss, ne.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt völlig im Kreis laufe, aber ich sage ja nur, ich verstehe, verstehe sozusagen diesen diesen mentalen
Stress, den das vielleicht bei manchen erzeugen kann. Und und diese Hilflosigkeit und dieses gut, das kommt natürlich noch dazu, dass ich diesen ganzen Prozess jetzt schon lange anschaue und wahrscheinlich wäre es jetzt anders, wenn ich jetzt grade 18 geworden wäre,
Aber so ist es halt nun mal, ich kann's ja nicht ändern. Bin trotzdem Jungwähler.
Er ist wieder.
Aber ich will nicht diesen Jungen aus diesem Zukunftsteam.
Also gut, hm ich habe ähm.
Wurde vor ein paar Tagen gefragt für eine äh TV von einem TV-Sender, ob ich äh bereit wäre zu sagen, wen ich wähle,
und ähm da ist mir bei aufgefallen, dass das Wahlgeheimnis ja wirklich eine Errungenschaft ist.
Für die wir als Menschheit viele Jahrhunderte gelitten haben und gekämpft haben.
Dass ich eine solche Errungenschaft ähm nicht einfach aufgebe.
Weil ich, weil ich sie gerade, weil sie für mich gerade nicht relevant ist, ja? In vielen anderen Ländern ist es durchaus,
relevant, da wird das Wahlgeheimnis, ist bedroht oder du hast nicht den Schutz des Wahlgeheimnisses und weil du ihn nicht hast, bist du in einer politisch gefährlichen oder unschönen Situation,
Insofern werde ich das Wahlgeheimnis äh für mich in Anspruch nehmen, einfach nur, um es zu pflegen.
Ich wähle aber nichts für das, was ich schämen muss, also AfD wähle ich nicht, CDU wähle ich nicht, insofern habe ich hier nichts zu verbergen, möchte ich ganz klar sagen. Ähm.
Genug übrig für das man sich auch schämen könnte.
Ja da da gibt's ja dann viele viele Erwägungen, äh ach so, es gibt ja auch noch diese diese.
Ach es gibt da alles Mögliche.
Ne, die an die Basis. Die Basis.
Die gibt's auch noch, da gibt's, da gibt's so viele Schwubel äh äh Parteien gab's ja schon immer, ne. Die yogischen Flieger und was nicht alles, also irgendwelche Tagesschau, Moderatorin ansonsten wie.
Ist einiges am Start, was was schon immer äh schwer hinkte, egal.
Ich denke, man kann sich aber schon mal darüber bewusst werden, in was für einer doch gefährlichen Situation.
Sich der Planet Erde und auf diesem Planeten Erde die Bundesrepublik Deutschland befindet. Ja, wir haben eine,
eine äh eine sehr alte Bevölkerung,
Wo es traurig sein wird, wenn die irgendwann mal alle weggestorben sind, aber dann halt zu einem wahrscheinlich sehr verspäteten politischen Wandel führen wird. Ähm wir haben diese Bedrohung im Land, dass äh.
Ja an an überkommenen Dingen festgehalten wird und Neues bekämpft wird. Ähm Innovation,
bekämpft wird, wenn sie außerhalb des Dieselmotors stattfindet, in der wir eine nicht zukunftsfähige Infrastruktur haben und,
schleunigst daran etwas tun müssen, indem wir eine Bildungspolitik haben, die.
Die Existenz von Computern und Internet auch 221 noch so lange wie möglich vor Kindern verheimlichen möchte, in der Lehrerinnen und Lehrer keine,
Digitalkompetenzausbildung angedeiht in der die Kinder nicht im Umgang mit diesen Medien,
geschult werden oder nicht angemessen und strukturiert und und zukunftsfähig geschult werden.
Einzelne Ausnahmen darf es im immer geben aufgrund des ehrenamtlichen Engagements von engagierten äh Lehrerinnen und Lehrern, aber das reicht nicht für,
ein Land, ja? Äh oder für einen für einen,
Für eine Nation. Und äh wir sind hier, wenn wir dann noch diese ganze,
Klimasituation mit dazunehmen, sind wir wirklich in einer ja ich würde sagen.
Sehr kritischen Situationen und das Bittere ist sie, wir sind sogar hinter dem Wendepunkt. Ja, es ist ja nicht so, als wäre, als könnte man sagen, wenn wir jetzt das Rudern rumreißen, können wir alles ungemach noch abwenden,
Das Einzige, was wir jetzt noch machen können, ist dieses Ungemarr noch ein bisschen mindern. Wir haben nicht die Option zu sagen, es wird jetzt alles.
Wir können nur noch sagen, lasst uns versuchen, dass es nicht noch viel, viel, viel schlimmer wird, was in diesem Land los ist. Und möchten.
Regiert werden, die sich rechts und links die Taschen vollstecken mit den Masken, mit der mit den mit dieser Masken-Affäre, mit.
Mit diesen Scheuer, äh diese März und was da alles für Leute kommen, ja,
dir die Corona-Situation in Nordrhein-Westfalen an, guck dir den Digitalisierungszustand von Deutschland an. Guck dir an, was alleine in den letzten vier Jahren wieder äh äh entschieden wurde,
Ausweitung äh von Staatstrojanern,
aufgeheimdienste, entsprechende Ausweitung noch für die Bundespolizei. Vorratsdatensprechung immer diskutiert. IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei Punkt null, kompletter äh.
Versagen. Genauso wie eigentlich alles andere, was äh vom Innenminister Horst Seehofer äh veranstaltet wurde. Biometrische Massenüberwachung. Scheinbeteiligung in den in den politischen Auseinandersetzung,
prozessen, wo den Verbänden irgendwie zwei Tage vorher,
ein komplett neuer Referentinnentwurf rübergeworfen wird. Stetige Angriffe auf Verschlüsselung vom Innenministerium.
Upload-Filter, Verzicht auf Geheimdienstkontrolle. Hier, BND-Gesetz und so weiter. Wir können mit diesen Leuten.
Und das ist nur der digitale Bereich, nicht in eine Zukunft gehen. Das ist völlig unerheblich, wie viele Basswörter, die in, in, in ihre in ihre Parteiprogramme malen.
Dorothee Bär. Also ganz ehrlich, ich hatte vergessen, dass es diese Frau gibt und das ist eine Katastrophe, weil ich mich die ganze Zeit mit Netzpolitik auseinandersetze und von ihr nicht, nichts.
Irgendwie bei uns vorkommt, was diese Person macht.
Vier Jahre im Amt.
Ja, aber jetzt äh schauen wir uns mal an hier dieses Zukunftsteam, über das wir ja hier äh gelacht haben, ne? Das ist äh wird in in der süddeutschen äh bezeichnet von
Robert Rossmann als das Verzweiflungsteam, ja? Und hier gibt's eine eine sehr schöne Feststellung. Ähm,
Laschet am Freitag gesagt, wir sind digital nicht so aufgestellt, wie wir es sein müssten. Da hat er recht.
Aber warum er glaubt, dass deshalb Dorothee Bär in sein Team muss, bleibt sein Geheimnis. Die CSU-Politikerin war in den vergangenen acht Jahren erst parlamentarische Staatssekretärin im Bundesministerium für Verkehr und digitale Infrastruktur, dann,
für die Digitalisierung zuständige Staatsministerin bei der Bundeskanzlerin. Sie ist also entweder mitverantwortlich für die Misere oder nicht durchsetzungsstark,
Am Freitag hat sie angekündigt, dem Staat ein Update verpassen und einen neuen digitalen Turbo zünden zu wollen. Warum soll das jetzt auf einmal klappen?
Und diese Frage ist oder diese Frage, die hier äh in diesem Kommentar Meinungsbeitrag äh in der Süddeutschen Zeitung äh gestellt wird, ist.
Denke ich, für diese Wahl die Entscheidende, ne? Wir haben vier Legislaturperioden Merkel gehabt. Ähm ich bin mit,
einigen Dingen, die Angela Merkel gemacht hat, enorm glücklich. Ja, sie war, also sie haben sie auch, glaube ich, öfter als die einzig äh scheinbar
Erwachsene äh in wahlweise der CDU CSU oder auch der Regierung oder auch oder vielleicht auch im Land oder auch im internationalen Vergleich der der Staatsoberhaupttag äh gesehen.
Aber dieses Land, diese Bundesrepublik Deutschland, steht.
Und in einer in einer Zeit, in der sie sich enorm dynamisch erneuern und verändern muss. Und das tut sie seit,
ja, mehreren äh Legislaturperioden. Und das muss ein Ende haben, sonst sind wir hier die Gearschten und zwar in jeder Dimension.
Ja, ich meine, jetzt äh haben wir natürlich hier die CDU schon ganz gut ähm runtergemacht in dieser Beziehung und sicherlich ist die CDU da auch ein großer Faktor, aber ich würde jetzt äh die Beteiligung der SPD in den letzten Regierungen, in den letzten Jahrzehnten jetzt auch nicht äh kleinreden wollen, weil da sehe ich jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt genauso wenig Auf
und genauso wenig Checkung. Gerade in den Ländern, wo sie dann irgendwie auch mal ähm an der Regierung äh sind, da passiert ja eigentlich genau so wenig.
Also es ist schon so ein inneren deutsches Problem,
Und deswegen bin ich mir eben auch gar nicht so sicher, welche Kraft das jetzt eigentlich ähm noch groß auf.
Und aufheben soll. Ich hatte ja hier schon vor einiger Zeit mal gesagt, dass ich eigentlich den Glauben jetzt verloren habe. Ich ich glaube nicht mehr dran.
Klar müssten wir uns schneller bewegen. Wir werden das aber nicht tun. Es ist einfach, ist völlig egal, wie diese Wahl ausgeht. Ich sehe niemanden.
Der äh das auch nur ansatzweise verkörpert, geschweige denn selbst wenn es äh einzelne Personen gibt, die das sehr wohl verkörpern könnten, dass dass diese Person in irgendeiner Form mehrheitsfähig ist,
das Land ist einfach noch nicht da angekommen, sieht es nicht, checkt es nicht, versteht es nicht,
klar, wer so auf das internationale Geschehen mehr, mehr blickt und natürlich auch grade jetzt so die Dynamik des Netzes mehr im im Blick hat.
Sieht, was da in China passiert. Die sowohl die wirtschaftliche äh Entwicklung, aber halt auch so die gesellschaftliche
Entwicklung und wie sehr die auf ähm
neue Technologien setzen und wie sehr es ihnen ja jetzt auch schon gelungen ist, äh in zunehmenden Maße uns einfach diese ganzen Zukunftstechnologien, für die wir uns immer so berühmt haben und die ja für so einen relativ kleines Land
wie es Deutschland eben ist, im Vergleich. Ähm uns ja ein eine Rolle und einen Vorsprung.
Ähm auch gesichert hat. So technologisch
ist es halt einfach wichtig, äh am Ball zu bleiben. So, aber wo werden denn die Solarpanele gebaut? Wo werden sie denn irgendwie auch überhaupt erfolgreich äh weiterentwickelt? Wo findet überhaupt nennenswerte äh Zukunftsentwicklung statt? Da ist Deutschland halt,
nur in Teilbereichen überhaupt da und die Geschwindigkeit, mit der Deutschland immerhin so der Ort, wo mal der Computer erfunden wurde.
Ähm sich schon in den achtziger Jahren äh ausgeklinkt hat aus diesem Prozess, finde ich irgendwie bemerkenswert. Gut,
vielleicht werde ich ja eines Besseren belehrt und ähm grundsätzlich sehe ich ja auch immer wieder
alles läuft in Sinus wählen und es muss immer erstmal ganz schlimm werden, bevor es wieder ganz gut werden wird, ne? Also man muss immer erstmal in so ein richtiges Loch fallen und das ist so richtig spüren, bis dann auch so ein, so ein, so ein.
Aber wir fallen da seit 16 Jahren rein.
Geht's halt noch tiefer.
Wir sind einfach noch nie unten angekommen. Du spürst schon die Kratzspuren so, aber das ist äh das ist nur, weil du an der Steilküste runterfliegst. So, der der eigentliche Aufschlag äh kommt halt erst noch.
Genau, der Fall ist gar nicht so schlimm. Am Fall ist doch keiner gestorben.
Wieso denn so schön, schön windig hier.
Fallen ist kein Problem. Äh Aufschlag ist ein Problem.
Aber ähm vielleicht kann man ja auch mal so ein bisschen mal versuchen so, okay was könnte denn eigentlich, also inwiefern kann denn eine Wahlentscheidung unter Umständen wirklich jetzt zu einer Verbesserung der Situation bei,
ne? Ich meine, es hat natürlich.
Also immer wenn jemand das sagt, äh muss dieses klassische Zitat gebracht werden. Da kommen wir jetzt nicht dran vorbei. Wenn Wahlen was ändern würden, wären sie verboten.
Ja, kann schon sein. Aber vielleicht kommen wir ja auch zu diesem Schluss,
so äh weil es gibt ja dann immer so Wahlomaten und so, ich habe da auch immer ein bisschen drin rumgeklickt und äh ist auch irgendwie alles Unsinn, weil was Wahlprogramme aussagt, das haben wir jetzt hier schon ausreichend äh äh diskutiert. Gibt dann sowas wie dein
Wahl oder deine Wahl.
Also ohne H wurde drauf rumklicken kannst und dann wirst du quasi konkret an den Abstimmungen zu bestimmten Fragen, die in den letzten vier Jahren passiert sind, äh quasi zu Abgeordneten und damit zu Parteien geleitet.
Es bräuchte halt schon irgendwie eine, eine, eine größere Bewegung und ähm,
ich weiß nicht, ob's überhaupt brauchbare Mehrheiten gäbe in Deutschland, die in irgendeiner Form bewegungsfähig sind.
Ich finde ganz lustig, übrigens fällt was zu diesem Wahlomat und so auf, ne? Ist dir, ist dir mal aufgefallen, dass das Ding nicht so benutzt wird, wie es äh gedacht ist?
Wie es benutzt wird.
Twitter anschaust, die Leute, die Leute nehmen das eher wie so ein Charaktertest.
Achso, was passt zu mir oder wie?
Genau so. Äh ich bin oh shit, ich bin äh ich bin nicht 0 Prozent AfD. Ich muss an mir arbeiten
ja? Oder oh shit, ich bin äh äh siebenundachtzig, ich ich bin nur siebenundachtzig Prozent Linke, ich habe die hundert äh nicht geschafft, ne. Ich glaube, die Partei hat einfach einen,
aufm Plakat.
Ja, nein, ja, ja, ja, nein, ja, ja, ja. Damit man halt zu, also einfach Ihre Antworten, ja? Aber ich find's, ich find's sehr lustig, dass, dass dieses, dieses Tool,
Wahl-O-Mat scheint mir ähm von den Leuten anders genutzt zu werden, nämlich als Urteil über sie selber.
Denn als Empfehlung, wen sie wählen sollten. Das beobachte ich zumindest so. Und finde ich irgendwie auch, also ist natürlich auch wieder ein total verqueeres Verständnis, weil eigentlich ist das ja äh äh total ähm.
Ein total hilfreiches Tool, nämlich nicht äh Wahlprogramme lesen und und und Wörter darin zählen zu müssen, sondern sich inhaltlich mit äh wichtigen politischen Positionen auseinanderzusetzen.
Oder was für ein Charakterurteil hat, hat dir der äh der Wahlomat gegeben.
Ich habe den Wahl-O-Mat, ehrlich gesagt, überhaupt nicht benutzt, ähm weil ich das ein bisschen sinnlos finde, mich durch irgendwie Aussagen in Wahlprogramm,
orientieren zu lassen, weil am Ende zählt das nicht. Da fand ich jetzt diesen Ansatz von dein Wahl DE äh irgendwie interessanter, war dann aber etwas Underwam, ob
der äh Auswahl und der Zahl der Fragen, die ich da bekommen habe, also da müsste man schon sehr viel mehr beantworten
jetzt auch nicht zu viel Zeit damit verbracht, weil letzten Endes brauche ich solche Tools nicht, um
für mich da was zu finden. Aber ich hab mal auf Abgeordnetenwatch DE ein bisschen rumgeklickt, insbesondere was jetzt diesen anderen Aspekt der lokalen Wahl betrifft, weil ist ja nicht nur Bundestagswahl, sondern es ist ja auch Landtagswahl in Berlin und ähm.
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ist auch Landtagswahl, glaube ich, oder?
Und ähm es ist auch noch äh hier Kommunalwahl in Berlin, also es wird so einiges entschieden. Ich habe irgendwie sechs Wahlzettel jetzt zugeschickt bekommen.
Ja, in Berlin ist ja genau, Kommunalwahl hier, ne, Abgeordnetenhaus, Bezirks äh verordneten Versammlungen, äh dann müssen wir noch diesen äh diese äh Wohnkonzerne enteignen. Da haben wir richtig was vor dieses Jahr in Berlin.
Genau, man muss sich ja mit so einigen Beschäftigen, muss man erstmal verstehen, dass irgendwie mein Wahlkreiszuschnitt für die Landtagswahl ein anderer ist als der äh für die Bundestagswahl. Ähm sone Details.
Ja und dann äh,
fand ich's mal ganz interessant, mal diesen Kandidaten hinterher zu klicken, ne, auf Abgeordneten Watch DE, werden ja auch dann mal konkrete Dinge gefragt und äh geben Antworten und so, äh dann kriegt man zumindest schon mal ansatzweise so einen Eindruck.
Ja, aber meine eigentliche Frage war es, was ist jetzt so eine ähm also.
Erstmal haben wir ja so ein bisschen das Problem des Wahlsystems zwingt einen ja dann doch immer wieder strategisch zu wählen. Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt schlecht. Ich fänd's besser, wenn man ein Wahlsystem hätte, wo man,
wirklich ähm das zum Ausdruck bringt, was man eigentlich so will. Ja, also das kommt halt durch diese Fünf-Prozent-Hürde.
Auf der einen Seite und vor allem aber auch durch die meiner Meinung nach äh nicht so geile,
Situation in äh mit der mit der Erststimme
Weil man ja da auch immer wieder denkt so, oh ja, eigentlich will mir diese Person am besten gefallen, aber meine Vermutung ist, dass die es ja nicht schafft. Und dann nehme ich ja äh eine anderen die Stimme weg.
Die meine zweite Wahl wäre, also gibt man dann automatisch auf die zweite Wahl. So und das das ist etwas, was mich an solchen Wahlen generell stört.
Mag ich einfach nicht. Ich würde das gerne anders machen. Ich würde sagen, so das wäre jetzt mein primär Kandidat, aber äh,
Wenn es dieser Person nicht gelingt, die Mehrheit zu erringen mit diesen Stimmen, dann bitte geht meine Stimme auf eine andere Person, ne, so ein Präferenzwahl,
Ja, das geht leider nicht und deswegen muss man immer so dieses strategische Dinge im Kopf haben, schaut sich die Ergebnisse beim letzten Mal an, schaut auf Umfrageergebnisse, schaut auf äh Prognosen oder was auch immer,
ähm und ist halt eigentlich auch nicht schlauer als vorher.
So und dann fragt man sich natürlich im Großen und Ganzen, wenn wir jetzt einfach mal bei der Bundestagswahl bleiben, weil Berlin Locals äh tut jetzt hier erstmal nix äh zur Sache, auch wenn's da.
Noch spannender ist, wie ich finde, als im Bund, aber da haben wir eben jetzt diese diesen, ja, Block.
CDU, CSU, ja? Ich denke nicht, dass sie äh in irgendeiner Form auf Bundesebene auch nur ansatzweise mit der AfD was machen würden, also die AfD nimmt einfach allen nur die Stimmen weg.
Aber sicherlich auch der CDU und das ist ja für ihr Programm dann auch äh
die Art und Weise, wie sie sich so geben, äh auf jeden Fall auch ein Thema, ne? Auf der einen Seite müssen sie so ein bisschen radikalinskimäßig äh rüberkommen und Themen besetzen, weil es ist ja der,
Der Pfeil in, in, in, in der Seite der CDU schon immer, die sich ja immer gesagt haben, eigentlich darf's äh rechts neben uns keine Partei geben und jetzt sind diese ganzen Rechtsausleger, die sie früher immer eingeheckt bekommen, äh sind halt einfach gegangen.
Und auf der anderen Seite droht jetzt irgendwie eine medial wieder erstarkte SPD ihnen auch noch die Mitte streitig zu machen und haben halt nur Armin Laschet. Da können sie einem schon wirklich leid tun.
So, sagen wir mal äh es geht jetzt so in etwa so aus wie jetzt diese.
Prognosen, Wahlumfragen in irgendeiner Form. Prognose ist großes Wort, ne? Diese Wahlumfragen,
nahelegen, wie es vielleicht sein könnte, dass tatsächlich die SPD das Unmögliche schafft und mehr Stimmen bekommt als die CDU und damit ja dann potentiell äh erste Adresse wäre ein Kanzler zu stellen.
Was würde dann dabei rauskommen? Gibt's dann irgendwas anderes als eine große äh Koalition?
Na ja, also die die meine Hoffnung wäre etwas an ein anderes Ergebnis.
Ja, gut, klar, aber ist ja kein Wunsch, äh, Konzert. Ich frag sozusagen, was, was.
Ich dachte ehrlich gesagt schon. Ich dachte, ich dachte, ehrlich gesagt schon, dass eine Wahl ein Wunschkonzert ist, ja, doch, aber du hast Recht. Dieses Ergebnis ist meistens keins, ne?
Genau, so und meine, gut, derzeit, also es könnte natürlich auch sein, die Grünen werden die stärkste Kraft, so.
Auch da weiß man nicht so richtig, in welcher Konstellation äh sie sich äh rumschlagen würden. So und dann kann man halt überlegen
Okay, stärke ich jetzt die Partei, von der ich denke, dass sie vielleicht noch grade soeben eine Chance hat, äh stärkste Partei zu werden. Ja, um da die Stimme anzuliefern.
Ja, also,
Kurz gesagt, wenn man jetzt mit der CDU nicht klarkommt, stärke ich je nach wie mein eigenes Lager ist, die SPD oder die Grünen, um da äh Zünglein an der Waage sein zu können, ja, oder äh
wähle ich ähm einen allgemeinen Trend,
Ja, wie zum Beispiel die Linkspartei, um dann eine Koalition zu empfehlen, damit die nicht so eine große Koalition ist.
Das sind so Fragestellungen, die man hat so, aber es ist halt alles auch so entkoppelt von den eigentlichen Fragestellungen.
Ja und welchen Schluss ziehst du daraus?
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so richtig. Also ich habe.
Bin da äh äh bei bei diesen beiden äh äh Dingen wirklich noch
ein wenig am Hin und Her überlegen, ne? Und das ist das, was ich eingangs meinte, während ich früher einfach so, ja, das finde ich jetzt am tollsten und das äh repräsentiert mich am meisten. Und jetzt so
Gott, jetzt muss aber auch tatsächlich eine Stimme abgeben, die wirklich real gezählt wird, äh was möchtest du, dass diese Stimme theoretisch in diesem Prozess.
Unterstützt und versuch's halt auch immer so ein bisschen so im Kollektiv zu denken. Was habe ich für ein Gefühl, was alle anderen tun? Ne, es ist.
Also es gibt da ja ähm.
Diese beiden Schulen über über diese Situation nachzudenken, ne? Es gibt einmal die die Leute, die sehr vehement sagen, pass auf, äh diese,
Die Idee dieser Wahl ist, dass du die wählst, die deine Interessen am besten zu versprechen, zu vertreten.
Und wenn das alle machen, hast du auch das Problem nicht.
Ja? Wenn deine Interessen halt nicht ausreichend vertreten werden, gut, dann äh schafft's eben diese Partei nicht in den ähm in den Bundestag.
Das ist natürlich so eine so ein Idealvorstellung ähm.
Die zuletzt auch einfach daran scheitert, dass es viel zu viele Parteien gibt, ne? Es ist äh, die da antreten. Also, es ist sehr gut möglich,
ich war ich also vielleicht auch so ein Wahlomat oder so, ne aber es ist sehr gut möglich, dass es irgendwo eine Partei gibt, die ich gar nicht angeguckt habe, die äh im Prinzip den Linusismus einführen möchte und äh ich das nicht weiß
ja? Und ihr das auch nicht wisst und deswegen wählt die aus Versehen keiner, obwohl das die beste Lösung.
Linusismus, ja, da ist alles am besten dann. Äh einfach hier das äh Linusismus ist hier mit gleich alles richtig.
Würde ich sagen. Der Linoismus klingt besser.
Lisolinoismus. Es geht nicht darum, wie es klingt. Entscheidet ist, was am Ende rauskommt.
Sondern was es bewirkt.
Genug, dass da mein voller Narbe drin zu stehen hat. Aber okay, pass auf, die ähm und die andere Schule,
Ist die mit dem ähm ja,
Taktisch wählen unter Berücksichtigung äh des vermuteten Wahlverhaltens anderer. Ja, also dieses äh ähm,
Grünen wählst du jetzt, wenn wenn du grün wählst, dann passiert aber Folgendes, deswegen wähle lieber Links oder oder oder irgendwie derartige ähm derartige Erwägungen, ja? Dass dann auch irgendwie so
ja äh oder dass da Leute sagen, okay, hm, wenn mein Ziel ist, ähm Armin Laschet.
Nicht Kanzler werden zu lassen, dann muss ich ähm SPD wählen, weil die gerade den aussichtsreichsten Kandidaten stellt, ein mehr,
zu bekommen, äh mehr Stimmen zu erhalten als die CDU und damit ist er hat im,
sagt jetzt einfach so, also angeblich oder auch nicht, ist egal, ne, aber dass man dann daraus äh Erwägungen ableitet und sagt, okay, ich werde jetzt strategisch die SPD um äh um um größeres Unheil abzuwählen, ne? Und die geben dann und beide ähm,
Beide Schulen werfen sich jeweils eigentlich vor, die Demokratie nicht verstanden zu haben, ne? Wenn du jetzt sagst, hier strategisch wählen, dann verrätst du ja deine eigenen Ideale, weil du nicht das wählst, was äh äh was,
du eigentlich meinst und.
Nicht nur deine Ideale, sondern auch die Ideale der Demokratie. Und die die gehen die anderen lautet der Vorwurf, ne? Du du verkennst quasi die Anforderungen der Realpolitik und verbleibst in in einer Utopie,
ähm sodass du äh dann eben einen Beitrag zur Wahl leistest,
der wertlos ist. Ne, das ist ja auch sehr häufig so dieser äh dieser Aufruf, dass die Leute sagen, ne wählen nicht für die Tonne, ne? Wählen nicht irgendeine Partei ohne Aussicht auf Einzug in den Bundestag, weil dann ist deine Stimme de facto ohne Einfluss auf die
Politik, die nachher stattfindet. Das ist ja genau das äh die Herausforderung der Fünf-Prozent-Hürde, die du da auch äh benennst.
Ich weiß selber, ich habe da unterschiedliche,
Auffassungen zu, je nachdem wie ich äh da grade drüber nachdenke, aber es ist eine Tatsache leider,
dass die progressiven Parteien.
In Deutschland und das ist nicht nur in Deutschland so, sondern irgendwie überall so. Ähm.
Dummerweise zur Spaltung tendieren, ja? Also du hast eine eine SPD, eine linke, eine Grüne, die.
In vielen entscheidenden Fragen ähm sich sagen wir mal wahrscheinlich einiger sind.
Äh als äh als man es überhaupt innerhalb der CDU ist,
ja? Aber wenn du halt irgendwie sagst, okay, du möchtest dieses Land äh abschreiben und dir das eigentlich alles egal, ne, dann dann hast du nur eine.
Wahl, die deiner Überzeugung entspricht und für die du auch nicht taktisch wählen musst. Und wenn du sagst, du möchtest dich in die in eine progressive Richtung äh bewegen, dann äh hast du auf einmal.
Bist du halt gezwungen strategische Erwägungen abzu.
Anzustellen, ne? Also Linkspartei, dass dirigieren wird, ist ausgeschlossen so nach jetzigen Kenntnisstand. Ähm
gleichzeitig könnte es sein, dass dass äh
dass viele Menschen sagen, okay, wenn die eh nicht regieren können und die Grünen haben aber Aussicht, eventuell, dass das halt eine eine Wählerinnenwanderung von den Linken zu Grünen hast, die am Ende da darin resultieren könnte, dass die Linke überhaupt gar keine äh Repräsentation mehr
im äh im Bundestag erlangen könnte, weil die jetzt bedrohlich nah an der Fünf-Prozent-Hürde sind. Ich denke nicht, dass das passieren wird, aber das Risiko äh,
steht im Raum.
Und derartige äh Phänomene den Drang quasi oder die die Notwendigkeit, die über strategisches Willen Gedanken zu machen, hast du eben eher in im im progressiven Spektrum der Parteien als im äh konservativen Spektrum der Partei.
Definitiv. Ja und ist auch schwierig damit umzugehen, ne? Weil das alles irgendwie so ein bisschen legitim in der Überlegung, finde ich.
Und die bekämpfen sich aber mit einer Vehemenz, ne? Also wenn du dir da mal die Debatten zu anschaust, ne, also wenn du da irgendwie mal äh im, im, im äh.
Gott schütze dich davor, das öffentlich zu tun, dich dich dazu zu bekennen, dass du äh nach Überzeugung wählst oder nach äh Strategie, da wirst du immer ähm
jemanden finden, der der dann mit dir darüber eine erbitterte Diskussion führen möchte. Und ist auch verständlich, ne? Es gehört halt zu den ungelösten.
Problem leider, dass des Wahlvorganges.
Ja
Also grundsätzlich mal dieses Ideal mit das, wo man am besten passt und so weiter, würde ja voraussetzen, dass ich das irgendwie auch feststellen kann. Und ich würde bezweifeln, dass das überhaupt,
möglich ist. Klar, ich kann mir jetzt über die Parteiprogramme durchlesen, ich kann mir stundenlang irgendwelche Interviews und sonstige äh am Ende äh wird der Eindruck weniger Personen und äh weniger Themen bleiben und wie viel
ähm Übereinstimmung man dann am Ende wirklich äh festmachen kann oder auch total real,
existiert, das das bleibt dann offen. Wenn ich's allerdings andersrum,
angehe, erscheint es mir sehr viel effektiver zu sein, das heißt, ich nimm erstmal alles weg, was mich ganz offensichtlich abstößt.
So
und äh in meinem Fall bin ich überraschend, ist das so dann erstmal so dieser rechte Rand, der dann äh äh automatisch überhaupt gar nicht mehr ähm zur Verfügung steht, so und äh ich kann dann.
Also AfD, CSU, CDU.
Ja, würde die jetzt nicht im selben Topf äh wählen.
Ne, rechter, also rechts, rechts halt.
Na ja, also erstmal sozusagen so die die Vollnazis und so, ne?
Äh die die CDU ist in meinen Augen halt im Wesentlichen einfach nur inkompetent und äh latent äh korrupt und kommt von daher nicht äh in Frage, ja. Also so.
Dass mit den grundsätzlichen gesellschaftlichen Zielen, die sie formulieren, würde ich sagen, da kann man ja noch drüber reden
ja? Also ihr behauptet ja zumindest, dass ihr das anstrebt, was ich auch möchte. Ich trau's euch halt bloß nicht zu. Das ist das ist was anderes, ne. So und äh ähnlich ist es natürlich dann auch am am linken Rand und mit 1tausend anderen äh Splitterparteien.
Also am Ende würde ich dann auch unter meinen ähm unter denen, die mich jetzt erstmal nicht offensichtlich abstoßen äh auf der Basis äh entscheiden, was mich jetzt mehr abstößt.
Und nicht so sehr, wo ich meine am meisten Übereinstimmung zu haben. Vielleicht ergibt sich das daraus. Ist es ist eine schwierige Sache.
Hast du denn den Unterschied zwischen Erst-und Zweitstimme verstanden, Tim? So als Erstwähler kann das ja sein, dass du die Erststimme überschätzt.
Das ist die Überschätze. Inwiefern meinst du denn, dass ich die überschätze?
Herr, in meiner Wahrnehmung ist die Zweitstimme die wichtigere.
Keine Frage. Ich meine, die Zweitstimme bestimmt letzten Endes die Verteilung
trotz alledem ist ja die Erststimme nicht unerheblich und wir werden äh glaube ich zu dieser Wahl, wenn ich mir die Prognosen anschaue, durch entsprechende Überhangmandate.
Einen riesigen Bundestag bekommen, also es schätzung gelesen bis zu über 900 Leute, keine Ahnung, also da hätte auf jeden Fall das Reformchen
was sie da vor ein paar Jahren mal erlassen haben, weil das Bundesverfassungsgericht seit längerer Zeit ja schon darauf drängt, genau dieses Problem endlich mal zu regeln, scheint ja dann überhaupt nicht gegriffen zu haben.
Komisch, dass die, die da sitzen, das Problem nicht regeln, dass da zu viele sitzen. Das ist ja auch irgendwie so ein sorry.
Ja. Nee, klar. Zweitstimme ist am wichtigsten, das habe ich schon verstanden, keine Frage.
Kurz zu äh Erklärung für alle anderen mit der Erststimme wählt ihr die eurem Wahlkreis, die in eurem Wahlkreis kandidierenden Personen mit Direktmandaten. Das ist äh.
In vielen Wahlkreisen natürlich auch eine wichtige Stimme, klar, weil diese Person geht wenigstens dann auch auf jeden Fall gewählt als Vertreterin dieses Wahlkreises in den Bundestag.
Dass da ist es aber so, wenn man jetzt hier von für die Tonne gewählt spricht, ne, ist es so, dass wenn du bei wenn du da die Kandidatin, eine andere Kandidatin willst, als die, die nachher gewinnt, dann ist diese Stimme, findet einfach keine Berücksichtigung
Zweitstimme ist es aber so, die findet auf jeden Fall Berücksichtigung, nämlich in der Verteilung oder oder in den Anteilen der Parteien
in, im Bundestag und dann eben die Wahl der äh Listenkandidatin, die ja dann, je nachdem wie viel Prozent die haben.
Mehr oder weniger Kandidatin von der Liste in den, in den Bundestag kommen oder nicht. Und insofern hat die Zweitstimme den.
Im Durchschnitt den wichtigeren Einfluss auf die Zusammensetzung des Parlamentes, gemessen an dem Beitrag, den du leistest.
Zum Beispiel ich wohne in einem Wahlkreis, wo ähm.
Im Prinzip seit jeher eine bestimmte Partei ein festes Ticket hat und ähm für diejenigen, die diesem äh Ticket nicht entsprechen.
Die haben halt, ja, sie können halt ihre Erststimme abgeben, aber dass diese Person.
Ihr, dass dieser Person ihr Ticket strittig gemacht wird, ist äh quasi ausgeschlossen gewesen sehr lange.
Mal gucken, wie sich das jetzt äh in diesem Jahr äh darstellt. Ähm aber ähm ja.
Dass äh es ist quasi sehr, sehr aussichtslos, da jetzt eine andere Partei zu wählen. Das hat in diesem Fall bin ich damit auch zufrieden in anderen äh wenn man wenn man woanders wohnt, ist das äh vielleicht nicht so.
Was vielleicht noch erwähnenswert wäre, um diesen Punkt dann auch mal vielleicht abzuschließen,
es gibt dann auch viele Leute, glaube ich, die in dieser Situation dann auch einfach sagen, ich kann mich für nichts entscheiden, dann wähle ich halt lieber gar nicht.
Oh, bitte nicht.
Ne
Genau so, nach dem Motto, das hätte ja dann auch keine Auswirkung, aber es hat natürlich eine Auswirkung. Es hat eine rein rechnerische Auswirkung, ne. Also umso weniger Leute wählen, umso mehr sind zum Beispiel die all die Stimmen,
für die AfD gehen weil der Anteil automatisch
steigt und dadurch dann irgendwie noch mehr Abgeordnete dazukommen und sie noch mehr Geld äh erhalten
während wenn es irgendwie knapp ist natürlich, selbst wenn man für irgendwelche Spieler Parteien, die einen gar nicht interessieren oder die man irgendwie nur lustig findet, abstimmt so
dann erhöht sich natürlich die Wahlbeteiligung und damit singt dann natürlich auch der der Einfluss der äh sonst abgegebenen Stimmen. Also man kann da schon durchaus was mit bewirken und ich finde, dass das sollte man schon machen.
Unbedingt, also das wäre tatsächlich äh unsere Wahlempfehlung oder unsere Empfehlung für den September, möchte ich sagen, äh erstens.
Wählen, zweitens andere, die die damit drohen nicht zu wählen, dazu animieren zu wählen.
Dann natürlich keine AfD wählen.
So ein bisschen wie mit dem Impfen, ne.
Also selber impfen auf jeden Fall, ne? Andere Leute auch überzeugen, so.
Und ich kann ich kann aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, ich habe, also ich kenne.
Ich kenne wirklich äh in meinem Freundeskreis keine Person, die nicht wählen geht. Und ich kenne auch inzwischen keine Person, die nicht geimpft ist. Das ist ähm.
Auf eine Weise natürlich beruhigend, auf eine andere Weise schade, weil nichts schöner ist, als äh Menschen dazu zu bringen
sich zu impfen und nichts schöner ist, als Menschen dazu zu bringen, sich ähm an der politischen Gestaltung des Landes äh zu beteiligen, möglichst.
Dann auch noch äh in der richtigen Richtung
bei äh AfD-Wählern kann man auch drüber nachdenken, denen die davon zu überzeugen, dass zu wählen, eben auch wirklich äh totaler Unsinn ist, ne? Das sind ja das, also wählen tun ja eigentlich nur Systemlinge.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, voll.
Also da nährt ernährt man ja direkt den Leviatan.
Na gut, lass es uns äh abschließen.
Gut, dann äh kommen wir zur äh zu einem Urteil des Europäischen Gerichtshofes, das äh ähm ja sehr äh offensichtlich,
zu erwarten war, ähm wir erinnern uns daran, wir haben's hier sehr häufig besprochen, insbesondere mit Thomas Lohninger.
Netzneutralität ist ähm durch,
äh die Verordnung über den Zugang zum offenen Internet in Europa vorgeschrieben und äh sehr spezifisch sagt sie, sagt sie darin, es darf nichts,
ähm es darf nicht innerhalb einer Diensteklasse nach ökonomischen Erwägungen priorisiert und damit eben depriorisiert werden.
Und genau das machen aber zum Beispiel so etwas wie Vodafone, Pars und äh Stream on, weil sie nämlich sagen, okay, bei bestimmten Unternehmen ist äh was weiß ich, der Videokram ähm.
Kostenlos, das heißt der wird nicht auf Datenvolumen angerechnet und bei anderen Anbieterinnen wird er das, ja? Also eine,
klassische Benachteiligungs von zum Beispiel äh Media CCC DE, unserer
Videoplattform des Chaos, Computerclubs, ähm wenn ihr das den gleichen Inhalt auf YouTube schaut, äh und zum Beispiel Stream on nutzt, dann bedeutet, dass das,
Dass nicht auf euer Datenvolumen angerechnet wird, das gleiche Video bei uns schaut, ähm wird es auf das Datenvolumen angerechnet, also wird hier ökonomisch
unser Angebot im Internet äh konkret benachteiligt. Durch die deutsche Telekom. Ja, das äh hat der EUGH
ihr Vodafone und Telekom dann auch noch einmal erklärt. Ähm dass eben,
ihre äh Stream-Orden und äh Vodafone Partes mit dem Unionsrecht nicht vereinbar sind.
Hat übrigens Thomas Lohninger hier auch schon äh festgestellt vor vier Jahren.
Genau, das hatte Thomas den äh auf der Telekom Hauptversammlung im Namen der kritischen Aktionäre vorgetragen. Wir haben das äh gegen beide,
Systeme oder gegen beide Tarifoptionen haben wir auch als Chaos-Computer-Club uns positioniert und haben immer gesagt so, übrigens, ne, dass es nicht mit dem Unionsrecht vereinbar ähm
die haben es aber trotzdem getan,
und jetzt ist es natürlich irgendwie einerseits lustig, Jahre später zu sagen, seht ihr, wir haben recht gehabt, andererseits ist natürlich der Punkt, äh,
den wirtschaftlichen Vorteil, dass jahrelang getan zu haben, den haben die natürlich trotzdem, ja? Und das ist schon ähm.
Relativ übel, denn also Tatsache ist.
Und das war ja, muss ich auch zugeben, das Argument der der deutschen Telekom in diesem Bereich. Ich habe äh mit Vertreterinnen der deutschen Telekom auch natürlich über diese Sachen äh,
gesprochen über diese äh Netzneutralitätssachen. Da kamen so ungefähr so ähm so Argumentationen wie.
Ja, ihr wollt doch immer mehr Bandbreite und jetzt habt ihr mal endlich unendliche Bandbreite für für die Haupt äh Dinge. Äh freut euch doch
ja? Oder auch die Kunden lieben das. Ja klar lieben die das. Ich meine, wenn du denen sagst, hier pass auf, fünfzig Euro
fünf Gigabyte Internet und jetzt nehmen wir aber YouTube raus, was deine größte Sorge war bei der bei der äh bei deiner Bandbreiten Nutzung und du hast das jetzt auf einmal äh de facto wird es nicht angerechnet. Klar freuen die sich darüber,
Ja? Wenn du jemandem im Gefängnis eine eine Sahnetorte machst, mit so einem
bisschen, bisschen ranziger Sahne freuen die sich auch, weil die sonst nichts kriegen, ne. Also das ist äh natürlich eine eine etwas nicht so weit äh gedachte ähm,
Argumentation, aber eine, die, die natürlich nicht müde sind, zu,
ähm also auch im Sinne ihrer Kundinnen vorzutragen, ja, dass sie also sagen, ey, wir wollten euch hier dieses tolle Angebot machen, aber hier diese Netzfundamentalisten, die ihr euch auf Wert genommen, weiß ich auch nicht.
Hat aber vier Jahre gehalten, so lange braucht das halt, bis das dann mal amtlich festgestellt wird und so lange konnten sie den Tarif ja auch durchziehen, damit das sich alles noch verzögert, auch mit der Zukunft, weil Zukunft ist gefährlich. Da darf man nicht so schnell drauf zurollen.
Ich meine, ich glaube, die größte Sorge der deutschen Telekom bei. Also, was ja die die Argumentation hinkt ja leider auch total, weil wenn doch,
wenn sie sagen, alles was fetter Bandbreitentreiber ist, ist bei Stream on drin, ne, dann können sie doch den kleinen Rest.
Auch noch reinlassen. Ne, also wenn sie sagen, wir wir haben ein Netz, das da, wo es Abdeckungen hat, in der Lage ist, den den YouTube-Bedarf unserer Kundinnen zu sättigen.
Dann können sie doch bitte auch hingehen und sagen, ähm
den kleinen Rest, den die sonst noch machen, ihre E-Mails und ihre paar anderen Videoplattformen, die können wir denen da auch noch mit reinmischen. Da braucht man nicht jetzt eine Netzneutralitätsverletzung für vorzunehmen.
Na, aber okay
also deren Argumentation hat deren Motivation ist natürlich eine Preisdifferenzierung, die möchten halt Angebote machen an Menschen mit äh kleiner, kleineren Budgets für die mobile Kommunikation und Menschen mit größeren Budgets, in dem Moment, wo sie nur eines machen, für alle äh ist diese Preisdifferenzierung weg und sie
können äh eben im Zweifelsfall höhere Preise nicht mehr so gut verargumentieren.
Sie verdienen halt auch dann äh doppelt, weil sie auf der anderen Seite auch nicht mit jedem reden, ne. Ich meine, Telekom ist ja eh dafür bekannt, der einfach nicht so ein beliebiges Peering äh alle tauschen alles mit allen auf, sondern wenn du sozusagen mit der Telekom, äh wenn in das Telekomnetz willst, dann,
kauft in Anführungsstrichen, die Telekom, ja, die anderen Anbietern, die diese Zugänge so mit dem Argument so nahe erwerten, hier die meisten Kunden, also ohne ohne die ganzen Telekom äh Kunden seid ihr noch gar nix. So und wenn dann halt entsprechende Deals gemacht werden
wo ein Peering aufgesetzt wird, dann ist das dann eben nicht selten zum Vorteil der Telekom. Und das ist genau das, was eben dadurch auch weiter begründet wird. Und insofern ist es,
dass der EuGH sich jetzt hier so deutlich ausgesprochen hat und ich hoffe, dass es dann auch irgendwann mal durchschlagen wird, weil machen wir uns nix vor. Die werden sich jetzt wieder irgendwas anderes einfallen lassen, was auch scheiße ist. Da muss man nochmal vier Jahre dagegen klagen.
So läuft der Hase halt immer, weil wir einfach keine Bundesnetzagentur haben, die da einfach mal sofort sagt, so nee, Leute, komm, jetzt ist Schluss. Oder mal ein,
Eigentümer vielleicht der deutschen Telekom, wer könnte das sein? Lass mich überlegen.
Die Bundesregierung, ja hätte er durchaus da mit ihrem mehr als 50 Prozent äh Anteilen durchaus auch was zu sagen, aber auch die,
daran halt kein Interesse, weil ist ja eine schöne Melkkuh, die irgendwie immer schön ihre Dividenden in den Staatshaus äh halt äh pumpt. Also müssen wir auch dafür sorgen, dass da äh immer noch zu viel Geld verdient wird.
Der Gelackmeierte sind natürlich äh wir alle und insbesondere ist äh und das ist auch wieder hier CDU.
Am Ende leiden wir eben als Gesellschaft, als als Wirtschaftsstandort äh komplett. Das das war heute dich immer noch darüber unterhalten muss, wenn du irgendwo ein Unternehmen in,
aufm Land hast, dass du da kein, kein ordentliches Netz bekommst oder auch teilweise mitten in Berlin. Ich meine, hier ist es ja auch.
Völlig absurd scheiße. Äh es gibt halt nur mehr Stellen, wo es nicht ganz scheiße ist, aber so richtig geil ist es halt nirgendswo und das sind alles solche Moves, solange man das noch zulässt und einfach nicht eine ganz klare Agenda, sagen wir,
neue Regierung. Äh wir machen jetzt einfach Schluss mit diesem ganzen Unsinn. Kommt mal klar. In fünf Jahren ist die Nummer durch, äh strengt euch an, sonst werden wir euch so dermaßen knüppeln zwischen die Beine werfen, wie ihr es noch nie erlebt habt. Sowas findet halt nicht statt, weil das halt einfach alles
hinter den Türen zusammen gemauselt, weißt du? Oh Gott, ich rege mich schon wieder auf.
Ich denke, das Kernproblem ist also.
Dass wir diese Netze überhaupt mit einer äh Gewinnoptimierungsabsicht betreiben,
lassen. Ähm das ist eine Infrastruktur, man ist immer eigentlich ganz gut beraten von Infrastruktur maximal äh zu profitieren.
Und zwar für das Gemeinwesen.
Und nicht äh quasi die die Infrastrukturkosten äh in so enormer Form auf äh auf die,
diejenigen abzulasten, die sie beanspruchen. Ähm das ist ja beispielsweise also, wenn wir jetzt hier, wir reden ja viel über die Datenautobahn, aber es gibt ja auch noch die die Legacy-Autobahn, ja? Und ähm
die äh da da wird ja jetzt gerade auch quasi darüber äh gesprochen, okay,
hier die wird beansprucht von denen, wollen wir die nicht mal mit mit Maut behängen, ne? Und die LKWs, die da irgendwie durchfahren und so, denen wollen wir irgendwie Geld wegnehmen und ähm diese Diskussion hast du
ja? Äh und es ist natürlich auch, es gibt.
Was weiß ich, Transporter, die von einem Land in ein anderes fahren, von denen die Bundesrepublik Deutschland gar nichts hat, die aber quasi unsere schöne Straße äh äh benutzen.
Insgesamt hat aber die Bundesrepublik enorm davon profitiert, dass jede auf dieser Autobahn fahren konnte. Ja und und nicht gesagt wurde, okay, wir bauen die nur irgendwie unter Profitmaximierungsabsicht.
Ähm und das ist, denke ich, das das Kernproblem überhaupt, dass dass wir eine Deutsche Telekom haben, die,
ähm Konzerninteressen der Profitmaximierung unterliegt, statt eine deren
primär Ziel tatsächlich einfach nur ist, äh Menschens
Menschen ans Netz zu bringen. Und klar wird die deutsche Telekom sagen, dass das ihr primär Ziel ist, aber es reicht für sie nicht aus. Ja, sie muss sich äh weil rein Internetzugang anzubieten ist, erstens ähm.
Also ist erstens äh ermöglicht das relativ wenig
Profit und zweitens sinkt der ja auch, weil das enormen Konkurrenzdruck hat. Und mit der Zeit, die einfach immer mehr anbieten müssen, für immer weniger Geld. Das heißt, sie versuchen irgendwo andere,
Einkunftsmöglichkeiten zu äh zu etablieren, zu bauen, sei das ihre eigene Hardware-Linie, sei das,
irgendwann durch dadurch, dass man das große Netz ist gegenüber anderen, wiederum äh ökonomische ähm,
in ein ökonomisches Kräftemessen zu treten. Das willst du eigentlich nicht. Bleiben wir bei der Deutschen Telekom, wir haben schon gesagt, dass Sie
auch immer wieder gezwungen ist, sich neue Geschäftsfelder äh zu suchen. So sie denn,
sich ergeben und eines davon war die D-Mail und wir haben ja vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass Tim Höttges die D-Mail als,
Gaul bezeichnet hat. Und ich glaube, er sagte sogar, dass da niemand jemals äh was drüber versendet hat und es glaube ich, ist eine eine,
Eine wahre Aussage gewesen und entsprechend kündigt die
Deutsche Telekom jetzt auch die D-Mail. Also sie schalten das ab und sie teilen den Kundinnen, die das äh benutzt haben mit, dass das dass das einfach nicht weitergeführt wird. So, es gibt kein DM mehr. Wir machen das jetzt nicht.
Und das finde ich sehr ähm sehr schön, weil die Reaktionen darauf sind natürlich meine Fach. Man könnte jetzt einmal sagen, ja, es ist, es war einfach Bullshit, made in Germany, was ich damals auch äh so bezeichnet habe. Ähm.
Da bezog ich mich übrigens eigentlich über das äh auf E-Mail made in Germany ähm in diesen Vortragszettel, aber ähm gut, das äh das nur am Rande.
Es gibt Leute, die der Ansicht sind, dass dieses tolle System der Bundesregierung wäre jetzt vom Chaos, Computerclub schlecht geredet worden und äh hätte deswegen äh
sein sein Potenzial nicht entfalten können, ja? Vielen Dank für die Blumen.
Ich denke aber, man kann auch einfach mal der Tatsache ins Auge sehen, dass das wirklich einfach eine eine äußerst schlechte,
Technologie war, eine äußerst schlechte Technologieinitiative und ähm dem,
dass das jetzt ein Ende hat und dass das, es sah natürlich auch bitter, bitter für die deutsche Telekom, weil die werden da wirklich viele, viele Millionen einfach in den Sand gesetzt haben. Und äh ja.
So läuft's. Hätte sie doch nur jemand gewarnt.
Ja
Hätte sie nur jemand.
Wird sich mal jemand aufbringen können das Thema. Weiß gar nicht, warum das, warum da keiner drüber geredet hat.
Ist ein ein Vortrag über für den ich nur auf den ich immer noch oft angesprochen werde. Ich hab den mal jetzt hier in den in den auch nochmal verlinkt. Bullshit made in Germany beim beim dreißig C drei.
So hosten sie ihre D-Mail, E-Mail und Cloud direkt beim BND. Na ja
Und vor allem äh ach so, genau, was äh vielleicht um diese Debatte nochmal kurz äh anzusprechen, was war das Problem bei der D-Mail? Ja, sie war einfach nicht verschlüsselt, ne, also äh beziehungsweise sie war nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt. Und ähm da äh,
sie haben dann immer also dieses Argument, das war so köstlich, dass die E-Mail für Sekundenbruchteile
Für Sekundenbruchteile wird diese D-Mail dann auf den Servern entschlüsselt und wieder verschlüsselt. Wo du so denkst so, und die meinen dann halt so, sie haben quasi gesagt, weil das ja nur Sekunden Bruchteile sind.
Ist das ja weniger schlimm.
Das kann sich doch keiner merken in dem Moment.
Und das ist, oh Gott, das ist da kann man dann doch sagen so, man kann vielleicht doch Steigerung in digital,
haben, ja? Weil wenn man meint, dass bei digital jetzt irgendwie die Frage ist, wie lange etwas wie lange etwas unverschlüsselt ist, ähm da kann man vielleicht, da ist, da ist auf jeden Fall noch Steigerungspotential vorhanden.
Tja, so ist das.
Muss man sich noch neue Diminuitäten einfallen lassen, wenn's äh um Deutschland und digital geht.
Tja, aber okay, dieser dieser tote Gaul ist, ist jetzt tot, allerdings nicht vollständig, denn ähm die ähm die Deutsche Telekom.
Klicken
kündigt quasi an, also diese Kunden können den Dienst jetzt nicht mehr nutzen, aber hier eins und eins führt den, glaube ich, noch weiter, wenn ich mich nicht täusche und GMX und äh offenbar hat die deutsche Telekom.
Irgendwie gehört ja zu eins und eins oder?
Das kann gut sein, ja.
United Internet. Ja, auf jeden Fall sagen die hier, ihr könnt jetzt äh mit euren D-Mails umziehen zum.
Wir überlassen, dass der Konkurrenz.
Oh je.
Andere sind digital, Deutschland ist digitalchen.
Tja, so sieht's aus in der in der in der im Internet.
Okay, mehr ertrage ich jetzt diese Woche nicht mehr. Ähm.
Das reicht. Aber immerhin, ein paar gute Nachrichten waren ja dabei, oder? Bisschen.
War eine gute Nachricht dabei?
Na ja, klar. Die E-Mail hat äh abgeschaltet und Stream on ist illegal. Ist jetzt nicht die schlechteste Nachricht.
Schön sind gute Nachrichten. Und und immerhin haben wir eine digitalste Partei.
Wenn hier einer digitalste ist, dann sind wir das.
Oh je.
Gesagt. Leute, äh damit entlassen wir euch in äh was auch immer jetzt nach uns kommt und ähm.
Geben euch auch noch ein paar gute Tipps mit auf den Weg, haben wir ja schon gemacht und äh sehen uns dann nächste Woche wieder.
Bis dahin, ciao, ciao.
Tschüss.